okay this is the first time this is
being used
I just got it I can stop using my health
and human services gambled
wow that was pretty cool I opened the
executive session and we will open with
um
House Bill 218
you may know how expert our committee
researcher is in researching things what
I discovered this morning is she is a
heavy equipment repair person
foreign
ly watched her fix the huge photocopier
upstairs which prints on both sides
Staples and makes coffee simultaneously
and so because of that we have lots of
paper to hand out uh
this is an amendment representative
Bernardi
um
has offered in the place of the bill 218
three four
five
and thick of read it's
I will be presenting I will be
presenting the amendment for
consideration as we uh go to exec the
some folks have found it helpful when
doing so to do what we call a side by
side put the original bill on one side
and the amendment on the other to see
where they differ the amendment does not
differ that much
but rather than just say change line 22
to read this the entire bill is
foreign
I promised the members who are absent
that we would not have fun in their
absence so you know have fun quietly
please
it's hand lotion and it smells really
nice
foreign
there were two particular places in the
room that tried to break out into levity
and
pursuant to your comment about it while
you were away I I quieted them down
all right the chair assumes that we've
all had a chance to read the amendment
you will see different things that have
been changed and different things that
are added and the chair will entertain a
emotion on
um House Bill 218 as amended
um
the chair will move ought to pass with
the amendment 218 that puts us now into
discussion and so the bill is 218 we
will be voting on the amendment in a few
minutes
representative Moulton the others are
back so you can be funny if you wish
thank you Mr chairman I have problems
with this bill uh that it says that the
personal transcript is admissible in
court because there's not a way to prove
its accuracy
um I think that it is demeaning to the
court uh transcriptors that we would
question what what they are transcribing
as you know what that's their
professional job
um
anybody has the right to I think my
opinion is that anybody has the right to
make their own documentation but for it
to be admissible in court is a problem
for me
besides being heavy equipment repair
person the uh committee researcher uh
reminded me that the motion I made needs
a second
and so I made the motion out of pass
with the amendment 218 do we have a
second to that
okay uh representative
you may before it
do we need a motion on the amendment
first
yes so that's what this is
motion okay it's audience thank you and
representative D Simone seconded the um
motion on the amendment to the bill
um
further discussion representative
Raymond uh thank you Mr chairman
um so I went through this
um Amendment line by line and I just
want to extend my appreciation to
representative Bernardi for listening to
our questions last time
um and coming back with some changes
based on that discussion I thought that
was really helpful
um having said that
um I still don't think we're there and I
have some further
um concerns about how this will affect
Family Court we still have not changed
anything regarding whether or not this
applies to every case that's heard in
family court or if it's only specific
cases like divorces or
um child support or other things so as
stands this includes Juvenile Justice
cases this includes dcyf cases this
includes any case that is being heard in
family court that anyone could now make
their own personal recording of
um under item three which is line 26 I
have a note to myself it says to protect
the Privacy rights of minors the quote
personal recording of abusive or adverse
treatment of any minor shall not be
distributed distributed or publicized in
any manner I thank representative
Bernardi for putting language in there
because that was one of my main concerns
was protecting the privacy of children
in the state however personal recording
of abusive or adverse treatment
that language is
um insufficient in that no one's being
abused or mistreated in the courtroom
while one would hope without a bailiff
or someone intervening my concern is the
testimony that is being offered in court
not the actual abuse itself being
publicized so I need something in there
that would say no testimony given by or
in regards to mistreatment of minors
shall be publicized in any way I also
want something in there that says
something about we're not going to
publicize or share the identities or
personal information of any minors
involved in court cases I include dcyf
and Juvenile Justice in this these are
children who have run afoul of the
system and they don't deserve to have
their names out there on social media or
out on the newspaper or television it's
simply unfair to them they have they
deserve the Opera opportunity to grow
even if they have made mistakes and are
in the Juvenile Justice System that's
why we seal records of minors the last
issue I have on this one is Article 4
which is also new and it says the
courtial supply all parties a digital
copy of the official court recording at
no cost in a timely manner I'm thrilled
with working on the cost because this
chart that we got last time that shows
how insanely expensive this is is highly
concerning having said that what does
that mean a digital copy does that mean
an MP3 a CD a WAV file how do we know
whether or not people are able to access
that I know as you all know I had brain
surgery this year all my brain scans are
Now on CD which I don't have the
technology to access because it's
obsolete I don't have a computer I could
put that in and see and so this is one
of my big issues that I took up with my
neurologist like you're gonna have to
print it out because I can't access this
so so as it is I will be voting against
OTP
thank you representative Raymond anyone
else oh yeah representative Bickford uh
thank you Mr chairman
um my concern is more in the first uh
section which says which talks about
um
shall not waive a family court a rule
and I I think they need that and should
have that ability to waive
um I'm on a planning board and on a
zoning board and we have the ability to
waive rules all the time and it's
important and very helpful to the uh I
want to say client or
the parties
um in the case so I couldn't support it
for that more than anything and the
transcripts thing is
is I I agree
um not quite there I'm not against doing
additional transcripts it's just that
it could be cleaned up a little more but
definitely against the uh
not allowing the court to waive the
rules I'm surprised we even have the
authority to do that representative
Bickford I just discovered from my
primary care doctor I have water in my
left in my right ear which is why I have
been mishearing things
um they're supposed to drain me on
Thursday uh but as a result I did not
hear exactly what you said you are for
or you are again you could or you could
not support could not could not thank
you the first paragraph in particular on
the waiver issue
the motion before us
zero two seven six
to house bill
218.
moved by The Chair seconded by
representative D Simone
would the
clerk this is on the amendment we will
then vote what we wish to do on the bill
either amended or unamended uh would the
clerk please call the roll
yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone
yes
representative Bickford no
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes
representative panic
yes
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez
no representative Greg no
representative Moulton
we have nine
no
and six
yay so it fails
do you have six seven seven
the motion fails nine to seven
the chair will
entertain it was six that would be six
wouldn't it
I mean because you it was ought to pass
so your yes comes first
I apologize
teacher will entertain a motion
on House Bill 218 without the amendment
representative Raymond I'll move ITP
please
itl I don't know where P came from
it's morning I T L thank you
I'll second that Beckford and that was
seconded by representative Bickford
thank you sir the motion is itl if you
want the bill to fail you vote Yes if
you want the bill to pass you vote no
on
house bill
218 FN
unamended the chair will please uh no he
won't the uh what do you do oh the clerk
thank you the clerk will please call the
rule
yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Bickford oh
representative excuse me excuse me you
may reconsider your vote if you wish
Yes Yes means no here no
okay I mean she doesn't mean yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic
yes representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
yes representative Petrina will be
voting yes representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
itl passes 16-0
it could be argued well it could be
argued a lot of things does anybody
seeing no objection the bill fails
um
my thoughts is there's some good
thoughts in here but it's not ready and
uh maybe another time
so
16 to 0 on to consent
um
who would like to write the committee
report representative Raymond
uh it sounds like I'm being volunt told
and that is fine if you can pass down
the paper I will call them I will
happily do that are you fine with that
before we move on to the uh next uh Bill
to exec
um we've heard
from
leadership
that
there has been way way too much food and
drink
brought into the committee room and
that's not just on the part of the
committee but it's on the part of the
guests all you may have in these rooms
is water
so I'll be repeating that again and
again
um
as long as I keep this in my mouth cough
drops can be add medicines can be had
next item is
108 and we have
Mr Sherman
can I ask you a quick question you may
amount can I'm allowed to um this is um
like um to control my sugar is water
with lemon it's not a drink I'm not
allowed to have this it's water with
lemon you may have that thank you
representative I think that's fine
thanks I know you'll be careful with it
yeah
gonna be passing around you may have
seen this before or not this is on 108
this has to do with
penalties for making a false report
let's see five six seven remember we
discussed that and we didn't know
whether other states did this or not and
although just you know just because
another state does something doesn't
make it right what we have here is a
50-state survey of what happens when
people make false reports
and I'll give us about five minutes to
look through this this should say
something perhaps as we go to deliberate
um
you know the old little boy who cried
wolf
so many times that when a wolf finally
showed up nobody believed him false
reports
um are bad so anyway
take a look
Mr chairman
yes hi
um my stepmother happens to be a social
worker and she can verify that in uh in
the state of Pennsylvania that there are
plenty of people that make false reports
now I didn't ask her what the penalties
are there I mean that'll be in here
right but I can tell you from her
experience that that there are
definitely people that make false
reports so
okay take a look through this take uh
the chair will entertain a motion on
I will
offer
representative Bickford in expedient to
legislate
and if I may
speak to my motion you may speak to your
motion thank you Mr chairman
um I weighed this heavily and
I would like to see something of this
nature however I was here when Mary
Stewart Gile was the chairman of our
committee and brought follow these
uh child abuse legislation and it was
during a period of time when the Roman
Catholic Church was being exposed
permitted child abuse
actions and my fear
and her FEA
was that if we take this route
then it will have a chilling effect upon
those
that could and should
make reports but would be in fear of
being
seen as doing it maliciously
and what we wanted was the uh people to
be able to
um
be be free to uh speak up
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman I spoke with the
bill sponsor to this
um and I it happened this fall and I've
had extensive uh conversations with him
and uh it was via email
um
he said that the intention of the bill
is to not discourage
Anonymous reporting
so so in other words you can still make
an anonymous report
but they encourage you to give your
information but you still don't have to
so
um I think if someone is making a report
in good faith
they could still give their information
or not
um there's always going to be an element
of people who might be intimidated to
make a report but if you suspect you
know a lot of people are mandatory
reporters I'm a mandatory reporter as
well and all you need is a suspicion in
good faith
to make a report
and this bill the intention of it is
only to prosecute people making
malicious reports in bad faith and so
the impetus is to prove that there's bad
faith but you're also innocent until
proven guilty so I don't suspect that
this bill is going to cause there to be
um
uh I don't know the word I'm looking for
but but
a lot of people to
be found
that they were making a report in bad
faith
but I do think that the people that
because there are bad people out there
that will make a report in bad faith I
do think there should be consequences
for that
I will wait uh let's go around one first
and um
chair would like to point out that's on
the first page of the bill
um one of the changes he's made is
reports made to the department may not
must may include the name address or
phone number of the person or persons
making the report
there is a whole paragraph on anyone
participating in good faith I am a
mandatory reporter as well and I once
made a report and I wasn't sure I said I
think this is what's going on don't send
the Army check it out I may be wrong
they later got back to me and said
here's what really happened I said thank
you
I made that in good faith I was not
punished for that we're talking about
the ones who are weaponizing this who
will call up and say that single mom is
doing such and such
and call again and call again and it is
not true it is weaponized these are the
people I think this bill is trying to
address
for the record this bill passed the
house last year it sat in the Senate
remember covid
a lot of things sat in a lot of places
and never got finished so this bill
passed last year we're bringing it back
any further comments yes representative
Raymond
um thank you Mr chairman so um as many
of you know I worked for dcyf here for
many years
um prior to that I worked in New York
state for child protective services
there which is the same thing and in
both States I provided training to
mandated reporters on when and how to
call the hotline to report abuse or
neglect and in general the advice that
we give people or gave people regarding
when to call was if you're worried call
and let dcyf or CPS figure it out don't
you try and figure it out on your own if
you're worried just call and they'll
screen it out at Central at the main
office at the hotline office or they'll
screen it out when the worker goes out
there the workers are trained to try and
make it as least traumatizing to
families as possible having said that
they have also worked on many many cases
where there is domestic violence within
a family system and it is very common
for someone to try to utilize dcif to
harass their ex-partner or their current
partner or their you know their child's
partner because they believe one side of
it it's unfortunate it's awful I've
worked in a state where they had this
law and I've seen the law applied twice
in the five years that I worked there
that was it twice where someone was
actually reported for false reporting
and I've only seen the charges stick one
time
um
I'll be honest this one really
it's difficult for me to decide because
I want people to call dcyf we don't want
to have more kids who are missing or
hurt and no one's doing anything people
need to call having said that I also
feel for domestic violence victims who
have dcyf out in their home like three
times a month because somebody keeps
calling on them
um so you know I can see where this
having consequences or even just being
able to say to someone there's
consequences if you continue this
behavior of calling them in falsely dcyf
still has to investigate everything
whether someone Lies when they call in
or using it manipulatively the workers
still have to go out with a clean fresh
brain and try and be objective about the
situation
um
so I worry about the effect but I also
see that 49 other states and DC and five
territories have this a similar version
of this bill so New Hampshire is a
standout
thank you Mr chairman
every person
every adult in the state of New
Hampshire is a mandated reporter
considering that we must remember that
all of those mandated reporters in this
state have not received training
so the statement of if you see it
it concerns you call
those are not the calls that this bill
is concerning
if an adult in this state sees that and
I think it was used in testimony a child
goes
to the bus stop on a rainy day without a
coat
and then the next day it's still raining
and that child still has a coat doesn't
have a coat and then
something else happens and something
else happens that may be considered to
some as child abuse and they're going to
call and they should call
however it's the concern for the child
it's not malicious
on the other hand as was just stated
you have somebody who's angry at another
person
and they call and again and again and
again and that is malicious that's why
we trained The Operators who are
receiving those calls
to try to differentiate
the difference and that's when they will
send a caseworker out they don't send
caseworkers out for every single case
so to protect the people who are doing
no wrong
I think this bill makes sense and this
state should have a bill like this in
representative panic
I'd like to share personal experience my
son was involved in a child custody case
about five years ago and during the time
frame that the case was going to be
determined where the child would be
living the mother had moved out of state
the judge had ruled that my son should
have custody of his son
that put the mother in a tailspin
and what she did is call the police
and put a report in that my son made a
threat to her life
which he did not
the police broke down
my son's house
the door and took
my grandson away
that traumatized the child
it took two years of therapy to get him
back on track
and it took a lot of forgiveness in my
heart
to forgive the mother for what she's
done but people do do
desperate things
when you're in a child custody battle
and this would protect
fathers who are in the same situation
that my son was in
all right and I think this is really an
any further comments we'll go to round
two representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman
um I don't disagree with any of these
things but I what we can't measure is
difficult to measure is the fact it's
going to have a chilling effect I know
if this passes
I'm going to think long and hard before
I take a chance on the system coming by
and arresting me for making a malicious
acting maliciously particularly if it
was well I wouldn't have a custody case
but anybody that does could be deemed as
being malicious and I think the division
uh dcyf has got a big task on their
hands but I think they're the right
people to decide
to do the balance
and
I I just if you ever had to defend
yourself in court it's expensive and
it's scary
and and that's what could happen to
somebody that does make a call
on their neighbor or whatever
representative Perez
yeah
um
for me I will not support this bill to
be honest with someone who is a survivor
of domestic violin
uh this bill concerns me a lot
pushing you to the Limit as someone
who's telling you
if you do a report if you call
you're gonna get sent back to your
country where you came from and you're
not going to be able to see your kids
this is it scares me
um for victims like myself
uh yeah and especially like I say you
know if
immigration is involved
immigration cases
um
people can you know um
take it the wrong way so I for that
reason I will not support one away
representative ball
thank you Mr chairman
um I would just like to comment that I'm
concerned that I'm hearing more concern
about the person making the report than
the child
whose family is going to get involved in
an unfounded claim that puts a
tremendous stress on the family and the
child through all the interviews and
everything that they have to go through
and I'm I'm afraid we're putting more
emphasis on the person worrying about
they may not report malicious means
you'd have to be doing it it to me seems
like it would be so obvious like you're
doing it repeatedly or it's so unfounded
or you can see that there's an intent
behind it
if it's a good will and you just say
look I'm just watching out for the child
that's seen there I I think it's easily
just it's easy to see the difference
between one and the other my concern is
more for the child and the family being
put through this traumatic experience
over and over and over again
unnecessarily I will support this bill
seeing none I'll call the question the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 108
an act relative to confidentiality of
reports made to the division of children
youth and families as has been noted
there's nothing in the bill that relates
to the rest of the title of the bill so
that's what we've got it's in expedient
to legislate if you want to kill the
bill you vote Yes
if you want a second motion to approve
the bill you vote no
you got it right I mean this is no means
yes and yes means no
the bill was seconded by representative
long thank you for that catch
I get it right this time all right the
clerk may call the roll thank you
chairman Pearson
let's see Ito no
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone no
representative Bickford
representative Nelson no
representative McMahon no
representative ball no
representative panic
no
representative Seidel no representative
Grossman
yes
representative Levesque yes
representative petrigno
sorry representative Perez
yes
yes I got confused representative Bolton
no
yes
it is eight to eight therefore this
of ought to pass
the motion by representative D Simone is
ought to pass do I have a second I
second it
hand
if you're for the bill it is now yes if
representative I'm sorry clerk may call
the roll I'm sorry that's all right
uh chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford no
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes
representative Seidel yes representative
Grossman
no
representative Levesque
representative
Petrino no
representative Perez no
representative Greg no representative
Moulton
yes representative Raymond
yes
and the nine to eight
it can't be a 97 I'm sorry nine to seven
it passes the motion passes nine to
seven
um
foreign
and thank you Mr chair you're welcome
the minority reports
uh it is not the job of the task of the
chair to figure that out but among
yourselves during a break you may
designate
um who will do that we'll do that this
morning
um I used to work to get that done and I
was told not to do that so I can't do
that but
um somebody very similar to
representative long is acceptable who am
I to say no oh no I'm not accepting uh
there may not be a Minority Report
there may just be a debate on the floor
so I don't know is there somebody wants
to write a minority I'll give you a few
minutes
there won't be a Minority Report
oh do you want it okay okay thank you
okay see that way I didn't know Mr
chairman can this go on the regular
for the for for new folks um well you're
not new folks but new folks to this
committee
um usually consent is unanimous or only
one
against everybody else
if it has a financial note it cannot be
on consent it has to go off to finance
anyway I cannot be on consent if there's
more than
two votes against everybody else it
all right uh I'm slowly figuring it all
out
aspective
I'm going to pass around now some
summary statements on the next bill
we're going to exec 126 3 4 5 6.
and you will see I even have a few notes
on it
um which I didn't erase before I handed
it to the photocopying department and
that's okay representative Spillane
obviously likes the bill because he put
it in but he says he doesn't mind if we
retain or dispose of it this is the bill
that wants to have the option of
payments being on the first or the 15th
you will see in the handout that you are
getting there's not much out there for
what other states have done on this
you'll see that on the last page and
even the two states that have done a
little bit about it they haven't done
much either so anyway
foreign
the chair will entertain a motion on
House Bill 126 an act relative to
choosing the accrual date for child
I have never been in a shire committee
than this one wow I'm not complaining
can we just discuss it then uh
beforehand we really technically need
emotion
but I never usually observe that do I
mostly
do you want a motion at least for the
sake of discussion yes
yes then I I'll make a motion
um let's start with the positive one
let's start with uh the OTP motion uh
for the sake of discussion
thank you representative Raymond is
there a second I'll second that
representative Moulton let's discuss
Mr chairman representative Moulton thank
you Mr chairman
um there's a lot of people in this
country who are living paycheck to
paycheck and I think that by putting
this is a harmless bill in my in my view
because Bill sorry a hard harmless
harmless thank you yep harmless bill in
my opinion because we're just choosing
if they're paying it the first or the
15th of the month so they're still being
paid so but by by putting the ball in
their Court they can families can budget
better
um there's a lot of stuff that comes due
at the beginning of the month like
mortgages rents things like that
um so by putting you know another bill
later in the month for some people that
might work for them
um because if people are living paycheck
to paycheck they might need to do that
so I just I I just don't see any
negative effects of this bill so
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman
um I am
appreciate representative Moulton's
viewpoint on this I'm actually thinking
about the person who is receiving the
money and they also have bills due at
certain times of the month my husband
paid
um child support for many many years and
he always budgeted and figured out how
to pay on time no matter when he was
paid by his company so I I am not in
favor of this bill
thank you representative Greg
thank you um I do I mean you can
obviously see both sides of this I worry
about us saying like Okay you're gonna
pick one of two dates every case is
different whether somebody is getting
paid weekly whether somebody's you know
getting even paid daily or whatever I
think this is best a discretion left to
the courts
um he you know the gentleman when he
spoke on the bill said well if you don't
want it the first you can go back to the
15th well you can actually do that right
now with 30 to 31 days sometimes only
28. I'll go back to the court I just
don't see that us saying okay you need
to pick one of two dates is going to
help anything and for the same reason
too we have not only the payer we need
to think about we need to think about
the payee and that is best left to the
courts to look at the entire situation
to decide
thank you representative representative
grossmann
thank you Mr chairman
um
I too think that uh this could
potentially create some conflict in an
already conflict area between the payee
and the payer in terms of going back to
court and filing motions
to change the dates that have already
potentially been set by the court so I
am not in support of this
foreign
yet not testified round one
representative DeSimone thank you Mr
chairman uh after lengthy discussions
with the prime sponsor although I am a
co-sponsor of the bill
uh it came to our attention that
although
the thought is a great thought and would
help some people
consistency is more important
so I will agree with those who will vote
moving right along to round two
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman
um this is more of a question
maybe I'm misunderstanding the bill but
I didn't think it gave
you the ability to just pay it
willy-nilly like I just thought that it
gave you the ability to just choose a
date but you still would have to stick
with it so there would still be
consistency that that's the
interpretation that I had
representative DeSimone is a sometime
co-sponsor
not consistency in the payments
um
we would hope that most of the people
who are paying child support would be
consistent that's not always the case
but my issue was consistency in the
court and when a couple goes before the
judge they have usually filled out all
the paperwork and come to an agreement
and to keep going back and forth to
court and saying well my employer
changed it from I don't get paid on the
15th anymore I now get paid on the first
and I don't get paid on the first
anymore I now get paid on the 18th
that's where I'm talking consistency
Mr chairman
may I
I just yes you may thank you Mr chairman
I
I I totally agree with representative
Moulton I I want to give her a little
support here
but I happen to agree exactly what she
said I don't it looks pretty innocent to
me I I know maybe once in a while so I'm
going to go back and forth but
um let them pick let her have some
choice
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh I agree with
representative DeSimone that um if this
bill were to pass you had the option of
one or fifteen so I'm going to go if if
I'm looking to
drag my ex
Buster chops any way I can I'm gonna say
yeah I'm gonna pick the first and then a
month later or two months later I'm
going to say
yeah you know what I'm gonna pick the
15th would be better so that's given an
opportunity to increase the conflict in
my opinion because you have a choice
between the first of the 15th so let a
judge tell me that I you only get two
choices no it doesn't say it here
no I have a choice between the first and
the 15th and every other month I'd like
to change from the first to the 15th and
what's prohibited me from stopping that
in statute it says you could choose from
the first to the 15th so I could see an
increase in conflict
taking a crash course in the law as I am
I would want the phrase to read on
either the first or the 15th day of the
month
consistently month to month I would
agree with representative long that as
written on either the first or the 15th
I could change that and bounce back and
forth and I could weaponize that
so I would agree with you that it's not
enough words here
representative Nelson
um I just actually had a thought when I
was you know when I was listening to
representative long
um this back and forth could also
mm-hmm
seeing nothing further I will call the
question we will be voting on House Bill
126 and act relative to choosing the
accrual which is kind of a pun date for
child support payments moved by
representative Raymond seconded by
representative Moulton the motion before
us is ought to pass if you like the bill
you'll vote Yes if you don't like the
bill you will vote no would a clerk call
Jim and Pearson no
representative long no
representative DeSimone
no representative bigfoid yes
representative Nelson no
representative McMahon
representative ball no
representative panic
no representative Seidel no
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez no representative
Greg no representative Moulton
no representative Raymond no
representative Perez when I called the
question were you in the room at that
time
then remove one vote you have to be in
the room when the chair says with the
clerk call the roll my apology I'm sorry
I was coming back from the bathroom I
understand that's okay nope it's one of
those wonderful times when the vote was
one-sided you may remember my story
about how one of our Representatives
fell asleep this was on a zoom meeting
and we did a redo because we wanted him
to be recorded So
so the motion the vote uh
OTP
is 1 to 14. now if we could have a
positive motion of
OTP now
if I'm smart at anything it's
surrounding myself by smarter people
okay itl
representative D Simone uh
representative Seidel I believe has had
her hand up to make a motion she did yes
then you had your hand up to point to
representative Seidel
okay you're very that's either a
tremendous Halo or you're backlighted by
the southern Sun I'm willing to go with
it was a tremendous Halo okay who has a
hand up over here representative
so are you confused upside down
no side gel is it's the side by side L
Greg is seconding
it's a representative
okay I can't I can't hear you sorry
Mr chair I'll make the motion of Ito
thank you
now we asked for a second
now
okay the motion before us is itl on
House Bill 126 relative to choosing the
accrual date for child support payments
moved by representative D Simone
seconded by representative Greg the
motion is i t l clerk may call the role
everybody here good okay
chairman Pearson
yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Bickford no
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic yes representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
itl passes 15 to 1.
and representative D Simone will
um you write the report please oh okay
I had bailed you out of the last one and
he uh objection to it being on consent
or would you like to defend it
vigorously from the floor
no objection to consent
on consent
I'm encouraged
foreign
consent
close the hearing on House Bill
126 and now open the hearing on House
no handouts wow that you don't already
have
and representative D Simone this is your
bill you get the honor of making the
I'll make a motion of uh ought to pass
please
OTP representative D Simone do we have a
second
discussion representative D Simone we
heard it before now make your pitch in
exec
thank you Mr chair
um
this bill just if you look at the bill
it's the Bold it says that the duration
limits are under current RSA 458 colon
19-a and the formula limit under RSA 458
colon 19-a Roman 2.
the duration limits under those two rsas
unless a party seeking Terror temporary
alimony pleads and a court finds that
immediate and irreparable economic harm
would result If the percentage formula
formula were applied
the court then shall make written
findings supporting its orders this is
uh in in answer to the multitudes of
people who come before us and say that
uh temporary uh alimony is financially
uh killing them uh it just is a
difficulty so if the current Formula
doesn't work the court can decide
um otherwise and and that's why this
thank you any other discussion uh
representative Bickford
um going down those lines at one time I
think we put a limit of Five Years on
temporary
alimony and this does this wouldn't um
undo that with it
you recall in the
may I yes it does not mention anywhere
in the bill that it would undo anything
representative Raymond uh thank you Mr
chairman
um so I took the
um testimony of New Hampshire legal aid
um to heart when they came and and spoke
on this bill and I I did some research
um on legal aid but then also on like
alimony and how this stuff is determined
and what the you know how does a the
case go through the court and I know we
all talked about this at length um that
day in a in regards to some other bills
as well because I just didn't know a lot
about how
um divorces proceeded
um and so my concern continues in that
um the temporary hearing
for where you establish temporary
custody Etc happens before all of that
paperwork is filled out saying what
people's income is saying like here's my
pay stubs here's all that stuff and so I
think that it might be challenging to
put our judges in a position where they
have to apply a formula when they don't
have the numbers to plug into the
formula and that's my biggest
concern over this language
is you know I like the idea of a formula
I think the formula is fair and
appropriate and I'm glad we have it in
the final orders I'm sensitive to the
foreign
thank you
yes
again
welcome
s
foreign
you need an extra set of copies for the
clerk
of what was passed out I need two copies
one for myself personally and one for
foreign
okay as we get going just want to point
out that I believe there is a luncheon
today in the cafeteria sponsored by
AARP a wonderful group that never gets
old
opening the hearing now on House Bill
491 relative to prohibiting the use of
prone restraints for minors and the
chair recognizes the prime sponsor of
the bill representative David muse from
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee
what HB 491 would effectively do is uh
three things it would Define a dangerous
restraint technique known as prone
restraint it would specifically prohibit
its use on minor children in New
Hampshire schools and treatment
facilities and it would require that
adults who use any form of restraint on
children be alert for signs of physical
distress and to immediately stop
restraining the child that they
experience difficulty breathing choking
vomiting bleeding or really any physical
red flag or warning sign
um prone restraint uh has become known
in in another context uh across the
United States in recent years it's also
a technique that is used by law
enforcement and according to a Cornell
study
um 79 fatalities I'm sorry according to
uh uh according to the Centers for
Disease Control
prone restraint uh the use of prone
restraint by law enforcement has
resulted in 107 deaths among adults
since 2010.
um but we're here today to talk about
the the danger of prone restraint the
danger of a of an adult often weighing
over 200 pounds uh using this particular
technique on a child who may what weigh
less uh than a hundred pounds is pretty
clear and Stark
um according to Cornell University
between
1993 and 2018 there were 79 fatalities
across the country uh at uh at
facilities and schools that actually
involve the use of prone restraint
uh our own restraint how we're we
haven't been able to uh to determine if
prone restraint has ever resulted in a
fatality in New Hampshire uh but we do
know that it's resulted in at least one
lawsuit uh in uh 2018 uh one of the
residents at the sununu center was
slammed uh to the ground uh and held in
prone restraint in such a manner that
resulted in uh the child breaking his
shoulder
uh so this is something that uh that has
happened that I think it shows um that
not only is there a danger of death when
a technique technique like this is used
uh or employed uh there's also the
danger of a serious injury
other people are going to testify today
uh as to specifically how prone
restraint causes harm and how it causes
trauma in a child so I won't get into
that in my testimony but I did want to
let you know that the uh the bill and
the amendment that you've received this
morning have been reviewed
by the New Hampshire Medical Society the
Psychiatric Society the Pediatric
Society the disability rights Center
dcyf uh and and several other
organizations that will either be here
today or offer online testimony
um this is uh in in many respects uh
this bill uh in some ways is a
housekeeping bill because our current
statute RSU uh uh our I'm sorry RSA 126u
um actually does prohibit prone
restraint now uh the problem with the
statute is it now stands is it doesn't
specifically call out or name prone
restraint by name as a prohibited
technique it doesn't Define prone
restraint and the current statute also
doesn't set any guard rails on the use
of restraint so for example a person
applying restraint there were there were
no guard rails that uh that basically
tell that person when to stop you know
when should you actually stop When does
the when does uh uh when does the
physical the stress of a child reached
the point where it's important to stop
this before harm is done
so essentially this building and and the
amendment address uh address these
issues the amendment itself uh is a is a
full Bill Amendment
um and what what it does is it changes
uh the statement of findings to actually
reflect the fact that the current
statute the way that it's worded
actually can be read and interpreted to
prohibit prone restraint
but one of the things we're trying to do
with this bill is to close the ambiguity
to make sure that the current policy is
a force is enforced more consistently
and effectively so that that's really
the goal here the goal isn't to ban
prone restraint because we think that
the current RSA already bans prone
restraint but what we're what we're
really trying to do is just make it
crystal clear to everybody involved that
this is a prohibited technique in the
state of New Hampshire we don't want
facilities to use it and that when we
apply any form of restraint we need to
put the health of the child first
so that's that's essentially what we're
trying to do and I'd be happy to answer
any questions that the committee has the
chair has one I have three family
members who are in law enforcement and
several who are in medicine and the
concern is for their safety as well so
so I looked at this bill with that
prejudice in mind that I wish to keep
those people safe especially from
someone high on drugs and an older child
who has great physical strength and what
I found pleased me in both your bill and
the amendment because it is talking
about keeping someone in that position
indefinitely which circling back on my
family said oh we agree with this we
don't want to keep it's if it is used it
is used very transitorially along the
way to something else that is less
dangerous so having heard from all the
medical people and all the police people
in my family who they signed off on this
thank you sir for this bill I'm glad to
hear that would you believe I had to
make a question I would believe any
other yes representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um I I was noticing the same thing and
it's in your
uh italicized
Edition here and you use the word uh in
the first sentence prohibited uh
physical restraint and then you come
down here and talk in the next sentence
about for the person's definition
physical restraint that involves a
temporary controlling of an individual
in a prone position now you accepted and
said yeah if we can do it temporarily
however you need to start doing it as
soon as possible basically what you're
saying here so you you said it's okay to
do it temporarily then you say it's
prohibited in the first sentence so I'm
thinking well maybe saying it's
prohibited and that is not the right
word to use that that should come out of
it
one of the things that that uh that I
heard when I was doing research uh for
the bill is that there are situations
where
um uh essentially sometimes it's
necessary uh for a staff member to
almost tackle a person in order to
prevent them from harming themselves or
or harming another person so in in in
that context that's why the exception is
there the the idea is
um there may be times when a staff
member may find themselves you know
using you know effectively using this
that the child may be on uh you know
maybe maybe on his stomach
um but the I think one of the things we
wanted to do is to provide clear
direction that that is supposed to end
as quickly as possible and you are to
move to another form of restraint and
and my understanding is that uh that
dcyf actually issued a memo in 2019 uh
that actually discusses prone restraint
in New Hampshire and as a result of
sending that memo out and we have a a
person from dcyf here today as a result
of sending that uh that memo out uh
several schools and treatment facilities
have stopped using prone restraint uh
and in their in in the place of prone
restraint are using other safer
techniques so I think that's the the one
of the things that we do have to
navigate is that occasionally there are
there are there's an need for the use of
this technique to protect the child to
protect other people at the facility
but the child's health and safety really
always has to come first and and I hope
that this language makes it clear that
representative Moulton I
think I'm just wondering if this is also
covers in homes like should there be
domestic violence going on or you know
for some reason
a restraint was used at home does this
also cover that
it does not
um
part of any of these restraint
techniques my understanding is that
facilities do train and have training
programs uh for their staff members
in the use of restraint
the average parent probably wouldn't uh
wouldn't have that kind of training
right the average would you like a
follow-up yes I would like awesome thank
you you're welcome my concern is if we
added language in to say that prone
restraint was illegal in homes then that
could add a charge for someone who was
being domestically violent
so in other words there's not a need to
prone restraint a kid but because the of
an abusive individual that's in the
house they're using it as an act of
power and control and by by
formulating that it's illegal then they
could be charged for such
and the the bill is the is now in the
hands of the committee to do whatever
the committee would like to do with it
um what what I would say is um there are
advantages to having a more focused and
uh and and narrower Bill uh in this
particular case and that
um this is a need to change uh and and
and I think you know we have a we have a
good Amendment a good bill in front of
us
um that I that I hope a majority of
members on the committee uh can pass
um my concern with what you raise is
that it might add another layer of
complexity that might raise opposition
uh so it's sort of
you know I don't think we ever want to
get in a situation where we want to
sacrifice the good and favor of the
perfect
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative Muse for coming to speak
with us today and for taking my question
um I have a question
um regarding
um RSA oh shoot I just lost it RSA
um 126 U
um and then there's a number of letters
after Roman numerals after that
um which has a lot of definitions about
restraint already in it
um
that RSA and part of I forget SB 324
something back in 2014 required
um a certain level of training for
individuals whose jobs require them to
use restraint on children within this
state do we know if the training that is
being provided through CPI or other
training providers covers not using
prone restraint and is there a way that
we can
um like find that out or does do we need
a bill that specifically says that that
training would have to cover this
particular type of restraint we actually
have some folks who are going to testify
later who are from facilities who who do
not use prone restraint
um what I would say is that does vary
from facility to to facility and and
part of the reason we're here is that
um RSA 126u doesn't specifically
prohibit prone restraint by name uh or
Define it so there's a little bit of
ambiguity and when you think about the
complexity of training a person if
you're talking about training a person
not to do prone restraint you can
actually show them a picture of what it
looks like and put a big X through it
and say don't do that in big letters
right whereas the way that the current
statute is written you're sort of
scratching your head going is this band
what's band what is it really Banning
it's it's any time it's it's a little
complicated for for for training
purposes and and the potential is there
for it to be misunderstood or
misinterpreted and we're just really
trying to close that loop we're not
changing the language so to speak of of
that but you know that there's some good
wording in there when it comes to all
forms of restraint
um but uh we just want to make sure
thank you representative for bringing us
this bill
what oh hi
representative Grossman has a question
thank you representative Muse for
bringing this forward this is really
important work
um
initially I was going to ask about
training so what alternatives are being
offered and it seems like we'll get some
answers potentially to that later what
would the consequence be
If This Were passed and someone did use
restraint in terms of a child's
um and I apologize if it's in here and I
didn't read that yet but so if we are
going to make it illegal you can't use
it what happens if somebody in a
facility does use it
the bill doesn't change uh change
penalties and and to be honest with you
I've been so focused on that one part of
the bill that I haven't been
particularly focused on changing
penalties or things like that I I do
think the uh there is someone here from
dcyf who would be much more familiar
with actually how this is enforced and
one of the things that we're also hoping
to do with this bill is by by clarifying
the policy
um we're hoping to make it easier for
dcyf uh to enforce this consistently
across the state I don't think the idea
is to to have people lose their jobs or
criminally charge people or anything
like that we just want people to
understand the policy understand why we
have the policy in place
so that essentially we're not
unnecessarily putting kids who are
already really vulnerable for one reason
or another it even more risk so that
anyone else from the committee for the
representative saying none thank you so
much for presenting your bill and now we
are going into the three-minute drill
which means 180 seconds
and at three minutes I have a cutoff
switch and your microphone goes dead and
I've already shared with the committee
the best speech I heard last year
speaking to a bill was 37 seconds long I
owe that person two minutes plus
whenever she comes here
so with this three-minute bill limit
please chair recognizes Holly Stevens
and she's got some handouts for all of
us
good morning chairman Pearson members of
the committee my name is Holly Stevens
I'm the director of public policy for
Nami New Hampshire Nami New Hampshire is
a non-profit Grassroots organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people
who are impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to support uh House Bill
491 relative to prohibiting the use of
prone restraints for minors
and our reading of the bill it appears
as you heard earlier that this is just a
clarification of the law and not a
change of the law
um the the exact citation is New
Hampshire RSA 126-u colon 4 I a through
C at comma d
um for us to know that prone restraints
are continuing to be used in the state
of New Hampshire is extremely concerning
and the fact that this bill needs to be
brought forward is extremely concerning
I reviewed a research study that was a
26-year study of the user restraints on
children and Facilities from 1993 to
2018.
they found that there were 63 deaths
that were related to physical restraints
and of those 63 deaths 38 were related
to prone restraints but of note 19 of
them the uh restraint right was
undetermined so again 38 of the 63 were
prone and 19 were unknown we also know
in a particular concern to Nami the
physical restraints are used
regularly with children in adolescents
and Mental Health Care the study found
that the deaths occurred with children
in adolescence
who were in psychiatric facilities
residential treatment facilities group
homes foster homes and juvenile
correctional facilities that was the
majority of the deaths
uh the evidence is clear that prone
restraints are dangerous and
disproportionately affect Youth and
mental health youth with mental health
issues and should not be used on any
children adolescents therefore Nami New
Hampshire urges the committee to vote
this bill ought to pass thank you and
I'll answer any questions you may have
thank you Miss Stevens thank you I owe
you 32 seconds next time
chair recognizes Michael skibby
from con to cook I only say that because
it's taken me years to learn how to say
it
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Michael skibby
um here to support the bill and the
amendment that is being proposed by
representative Muse I was policy
director at the disability rights Center
when the child restraint law was
originally passed in 2010
um and then when it was uh substantially
amended in 2014
my objective is to give you an
understanding of the reasons for this
legislation
um the legislation that led to the
current statute
um and the reason that we uh really need
to adopt this bill to to clarify the
current state of the law
before 2010 our office at the disability
rights Center
was involved in a number of cases and
investigations of
um of restraint causing significant and
serious injury to children in both
public schools and treatment facilities
at the same time there had been a
growing National understanding of the
inherent dangers of certain kinds of
restraint including prone restraint
the United States Department of
Education had issued some guidance
medical research had had become more
sort of well understood
and so senator scumbati who was the
former deputy director of the Department
of Health and Human Services and had a
deep understanding of restraint and its
dangers
sponsored the bill that led to current
chapter 126u
while the bill was being considered one
or two facilities that provided
treatment to Children
strongly objected to the use of the term
prone restraint in the list of
prohibited techniques and they
maintained you know stridently and
vociferously that you know
notwithstanding everything that had
become known about the inherent dangers
of this technique that they could do it
safely and
um but at the same at the same time and
during the hearings that were ongoing
regarding the legislation the chief
medical examiner of the state Dr Thomas
Andrew who is here today testified in
detail about what exactly happens to
someone when they're subjected to this
technique and how dangerous it really is
I mean here's among other things that it
interferes with the movement that's
required for normal breathing
Senators combati was very concerned
about the objections that were being
raised but it was also very committed to
the prohibition on prone and so she
asked us develop language
that would address dangerous restraint
techniques and positions without using
that term that was triggering so much
objection and so uh my colleague now
Senator Whitley and Dr Andrew and I
consulted about how to do accomplish
that and we came up with the language
that is in the current statute that I
distributed to you just now and I've had
15 seconds to close please I've
highlighted the sections that
um I think address and I think if you
imagine yourself being face down on a
hard surface like a floor or a table
that it would definitely do the things
that this prohibits it would cause
compression of the chest it would impair
the the
movement that's required for normal
breathing so we do believe that it does
prohibit it but that unfortunately some
facilities are still using it we ask you
to to adopt this or to
recommend passage of this bill so that
we can further protect the children
thank you any questions for Mr skibby
microphone
my concern my is the word temporary is
in here we're prohibited from doing
something then we said we can't do it
temporarily how long is temporarily I
think that um if I can grab it here
um
I think that the key phrase for me in
understanding that sentence is that it's
the temporary controlling while
transitioning to an alternative safer
form of restraint and what the way I
think about this is that when you
initially engage physically with a child
that is upset maybe you know in
um in a fight with someone or something
like that that it takes a little bit
maybe just seconds to gain control of
the situation and you may find yourself
with hands on a child with their face
down and that could be considered a
technical violation of of this language
so I think that adding this language
makes it clear that as you're gaining
control
you may have a kid face down but you
would not thereby be violating the
statute that's how I understand
transitioning is exactly yeah I think so
okay thank you any further questions
from Mr Scooby
saying none thank you so much are you
enjoying your retirement
I am thank you very much well I miss you
from the Committees here so thank you
for coming back good to see you
everybody yeah chair recognizes Karen
Rosenberg from the disability rights
good morning members of the committee
I'm Karen Rosenberg the policy director
of the disability rights Center I'm
testifying in support of HB 491 on
behalf of the disability rights Center
as well as the juvenile reform policy
Group which is a coalition of
organizations that advocate for the
health and well-being of our children
that includes New Hampshire legal
assistance Waypoint new Futures the
children's Law Center of New Hampshire
and the ACLU of New Hampshire so first I
think it's really important for everyone
to realize there is no evidence-based
research that supports using restraint
as a therapeutic intervention we're
talking about situations that are
emergencies when no other less
restrictive less onerous
technique can be used to control a child
who's in a school or a facility and so
representative I think it was Moulton
asked the question about how it would it
potentially impact families this is not
a bill that impacts families this law
only regulates the use of restrain or
seclusion in schools and treatment
facilities and Foster treatment
facilities okay so
um as as you've heard our law currently
prohibits use of dangerous restoring
techniques which includes prone but
where and for the most part facilities
and schools are successfully managing
even dangerous children's Behavior
without using this technique even
facilities that are under contract with
our Department of Health and Human
Services that are like level four really
you know very challenging children have
figured out how to address really
dangerous situations using safer
techniques when they need to put their
hands on a child but it's come to our
attention that there are some outliers
that it didn't really get the memo and
don't really interpret the law the way
it was intended and so since the passage
of the law we have become aware of
situations where children have suffered
serious injuries due to the use of prone
restraint including one where a child
suffered a broken a fractured scapula in
your shoulder blade another in which a
student lost Consciousness for a period
of time during the course of a prone
restraint so we want to make sure that
it is abundantly clear that we mean it
we should not be using dangerous
restraints on vulnerable children that's
really what this is about so
um and and also that if a child is in
any kind of restraint that the person
involved in that restraint needs to pay
attention to their health and well-being
and so that's why there's also in this
amendment
um I think in the original bill there's
a requirement that the child's physical
condition be paid attention to so that
they can be released if there's any sign
of distress
so I am and and I if I have time to
answer a couple of questions that were
raised I think representative
um Raymond maybe asked about complaints
and like what would happened to someone
is that you know you asked about
training
um so there is a requirement that the
Department of Education in New Hampshire
um Department of Labor in this it's in
the current law assist with training
materials and any reputable training
organization is going to train facility
operators and schools to avoid the use
of restraint whenever possible to apply
research-based you know Alternatives
that will help the child to learn to
regulate and de-escalate and will be in
Conformity with our state law
and I think it was representative
Grossman that asked about well what's
going to happen to these people we
already have
um processes under that's required by
state law and now in state rule for
complaints to be filed that's and I
think RSA 126 u9 and that caused I mean
so under those it's u9 and u8 depending
whether it's a school or a facility
that's overseen by the Department of
Health and Human Services so there's a
requirement that there be investigation
process and a process for addressing the
you know what injuries the child may
have suffered as a result so I hope that
answered your questions I hope I kept it
under three minutes
actually your speech was under three
minutes and then you answered questions
any further questions representative
panic
what is the definition of a child of age
wise well it depends if they're still in
school or not so for
um I'm gonna I actually need to look at
it so for for children who are generally
it's under 18 years of age however if a
child is either in the juvenile justice
system and is voluntarily extended their
jurisdiction of course jurisdiction
because they have not obtained a regular
high school diploma or they're in school
in you know through the public school
system because they've not earned a
diploma then they would and they're less
than 22 years of age those those
individuals would also be covered by the
definition of child it's meant to
regulate what happens in schools and
Facilities
one follow-up
so if a child came into school who's
20 years old
the school's definition of a child with
a gun
and the child needs to be restrained
that wouldn't restrict that type no this
does not prohibit schools from using
restraint okay restraint can be used
and what this says though is that we
can't we should not be using dangerous
restraints on people and prone restraint
which is actually prohibited under our
law given how our law defines dangerous
restraint should not be the go-to
restraint so if someone needs to be
restrained and that's a very dangerous
situation if that's the intervention
there's nothing in our current law or if
the law is amended that would prevent
that from happening with a goal as
quickly as possible to move to less
dangerous if they were if they were if
the if the restraint ended up in a take
down to the floor and the person ended
up face down then yes the goal would be
to put them in a safer position and
contain them
take away the gun any further questions
for Ms Rosenberg
representative Raymond uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss Rosenberg
um I think it might be helpful
um for the community and it would be
helpful for me
um are you able to give us some examples
or perhaps another speaker I'm not sure
of situations where restraint is used
currently
um in school settings or
um group treatment settings
um like a situation where
um people are trained to use restraint
that is appropriate to use a restraint
so for example like when I hear this I
don't think of someone coming in with a
gun that to me is a law enforcement
response I think of this as a child with
a meltdown am I on the wrong track yeah
I'm not aware of and I hope I'm never
aware of a situation with a gun but so
it's a situation in which a child's
behavior is such that they pose in a
substantial imminent risk of causing
serious bodily harm to either themselves
or someone else that's what they'll have
the law defines it so as an illustration
um there's some altercation between two
students and one student is you know
really wailing on another student right
so they're going to hurt them a staff
member could separate the children and
and and in doing so hold on and maybe
with another staff member too to the to
the child and to you know to eliminate
that to try to control that risk and
hold on to the child if assuming they're
still flailing and dangerous does that
help you yes it does I'm just I'm trying
to Envision the circumstances in which
this happens so you know a fight at
school or I'm thinking in elementary
school child who's you know having a an
issue of throwing things or something
like we've seen situations with kids
like with autism who have sort of a
flight or fight response and so we've
over the years that I've been at DRC
we've had such relations where child
bolts so they're like in the playground
and something interests them or
something's going on and they're bolting
towards the street and so that would be
dangerous and a staff member and teacher
could then you know grab the kid in a
safe position and prevent them from
bolting into the street that might be
another example that comes out pretty
regularly representative Moulton thank
you Mr chairman Mr chair point of order
please yes representative Moulton oh
excuse me that's right your sponsor
thank you thank you I forgot to announce
that representative Moulton and
representative Levesque are co-sponsors
of the bills so may ask questions of the
Prime sponsor only but no one else
thank you for that I meant to do that I
forgot that great but
thank you
thank you I'll tell you later about how
representative knurk and I almost got
thrown out for doing it but I'll tell
you yes anyone else for
oh I'll tell everybody
Jerry wanted to ask a question and he
couldn't so he slipped me a piece of
paper and I'm reading it as if it were
my question but Jerry is a doctor so
halfway through the question I said
what's that word at which point I
totally outed both of us
foreign
story and I've learned something today I
didn't realize that that was um
prohibited so thank you
so um you know this is Fox guarding Hen
House chairmanship here all right any
other questions for uh Miss Rosenberg
from
somebody who can ask them thank you
thank you everyone chair recognizes uh
okay
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
to the committee for hosting me this
morning my name is Tom Andrew I'm a
forensic pathologist and served the
granite state as your chief medical
examiner from 1997 to 2017. now since
retirement from State service I've
remained active as a forensic
pathologist as a consultant and in
teaching now I did not testify before
our legislative committees very often
in my 20 years as chief medical examiner
I reserved those times for
when I felt strongly about the issue at
hand and when I thought I really had
some legitimate expertise to offer
over a decade ago I testified on the
dangers of prone restraint and I'm back
today to support HB 491's aim to
prohibit prone restraint specifically by
name
that prone restraint is still used due
to language vagaries in the current law
is an anathema to one who has seen
firsthand fatal results from the use of
this technique as far back as 1996.
forensic Pathologists alerted by Don Ray
uh chief medical examiner in Seattle
began to recognize the inhibition of
effective ventilation during prone
restraint as it involves two key factors
in the physiology of respiration or
breathing
movement of the ribs and movement of the
diaphragm
now prone restraint re restricts rib
movement particularly and especially but
not exclusively
if weight is applied to the person's
back
now obesity of the victim of a fatal
episode of prone restraint not uncommon
I might add
is an exacerbating Factor because it
pushes the abdominal contents upward
restricting the movement of the
diaphragm now these anatomic factors
reduce respiratory volume the amount of
air that you exchange limitation of
respiratory volume may be of no
significance to a healthy person at rest
this is the apparent basis of the
misguided notion that this technique can
be practiced safely
but the circumstances of fatal cases
seen hundreds of times by forensic
Pathologists around the country and
several times by me personally
are very different
the victim has nearly always been
involved in a high intense physical
activity that prompted and the restraint
in the first place and then actively
resisted the restraint even after being
subdued they continue to struggle
incurring further oxygen debt now
additionally this victim is subjected to
high levels of circulating adrenaline
due to their emotional arousal mental
illness or as can be seen in encounters
with law enforcement
uh the use of illicit stimulant drugs
now adrenaline in excess has an
irritated effect on the heart
and the heart's ability to conduct
normal electrical impulses is impaired
and this is an unpredictable factor that
can bring about very sudden unexpected
lethal arrhythmias or electrical
short-circuiting of the heart please
wrap it up doctor about 15 seconds they
can kill in seconds
an experience has taught us that the
level of restricted ventilation that
might be harmless to a healthy person at
rest may be in such circumstances fatal
and this is not a novel Theory
a comprehensive review of restraint
deaths in 2021 in Medicine Science and
the law highlighted this
underappreciated aspect of prone
restraint
well we just got a ruling from on high
and it says that unless you are
testifying you may ask questions so the
connect Pearson protocol has been
replaced any questions for the doctor
representative long
thank you Doctor oops thank you thank
you doctor for your testimony uh the
questions sir
well I could have your people call my
people and we get a minute I'll think
um doctor with with respect uh I I mean
looking at this I've always thought of
restraints uh if they're on their back
and some of that consistent with what
you said when they're on their face I
mean I would think a larger person on
their back would have that
breath have you seen instances of uh
people on their back restrained
um that are uh detrimental to their
breathing or their health on their back
that supine restraint yeah okay I didn't
know that's what it was called well
that's if you're on your back you're
supine okay if you're face down you're
prone prone is inherently dangerous so
restraint
of any kind incurs risk
prone restraint when you're face down is
inherently dangerous
if I had a choice I would prefer to be
restrained supine face up okay great
representative Greg
so it's of your opinion that no matter
how good the training is anything that
this prone is is a problem it's not my
opinion I think that it is the uh
consensus of evidence-based medicine I'm
merely representing what uh what the
literature supports thank you so much
representative panic thank you for thank
you chairman uh thank you for taking my
question a little closer to the mic
please sorry thank you
is the amount of pressure
given to the person being restrained in
prone position a determining Factor on
the severity of the injury it is death
it is not a determining factor and
that's why I said especially and
particularly but not exclusively
in the prone position
even without extra weight being added
onto the back which is a rarity in these
situations there's almost always
something somebody across the shoulders
where the back or the abdomen but even
without that rib motion rib movement
against an unyielding surface like the
floor even a carpeted floor
is still a significant factor and what
does not what is not accounted for here
is the potential cardiac toxicity of
excess adrenaline that's why
that's why the restrained individual
even if in quotation marks is being
monitored
they can have a sudden lethal arrhythmia
leading to Heart stoppage even if they
are clearly breathing
right up to the moment that they stop
that their heart stops this this is not
predictable they're not blue
and if they have a lethal cardiac
arrhythmia
now the game's over before anybody can
do about it often before before they
even realize it because they're looking
for cyanosis or blueness in the face or
stoppage of breathing
representative Moulton with her Newfound
Freedom thank you Mr chairman uh for for
one thank you representative DeSimone
for reminding me that I was a co-sponsor
of this bill because that was back in
December and
I just I knew I had co-sponsored some
bills but uh this one in particular but
regardless I'm a registered nurse uh we
do restrain patients and I would wanted
to make a comment that I have to word as
a question so if you would believe that
in hospitals in
adult care only restrain patients that
are confused and violent or just violent
um that's the only time where we
restrain adult patients so they have to
be a threat to themselves or others and
in the adult setting we don't use prone
restraints like ever
um so and then the other caveat to that
is that we need to release them as soon
as they are calm
because they we don't restrain people
that don't need to be restrained so
um that's been the policy everywhere
that I've worked so
and just to so I was just saying you
know I was aiming it it was more of a
comment than a question but you're
wondering if the good doctor believes
this would you believe that what what I
testify having autopsied an individual
who died in prone restraint in a health
care facility here in New Hampshire and
seeing that policy in that facility
change yes I believe it and my sainted
wife who is a psychiatrist and was
employed at a New Hampshire hospital for
11 years saw any number of
necessary takedowns of people acting
Dangerously
but after they were taken down
as soon as was feasible they were
removed from the prone position
to a Supine position or other position
wherein a restraint can be more safely
applied
thank you doctor I'm glad you stayed for
questions if you had written testimony
that you were reading would you mind
sharing it with the clerk for the record
thank you chair now recognizes state
hmm
thank you
my name is Maria Perez I'm a Staff
representative from District 43 and I'm
here to speak on support HP 491.
I will say thank you for their sponsors
and the co-sponsors of this bill
is someone who worked with
um
this is very critical
I believe when someone is having
a broken moment in a crisis the lesson
that they need
is feel like I'm safe
especially when we're dealing with uh
kids with autism
and sometimes
religion
you know we need we need to uh remember
that you know uh we all different and
I'm I'm so thankful that this bill was
introduced
and I will ask everyone in the committee
to support this Bill thank you for your
testimony
and I want to see if she can do it in
and your time starts as soon as you turn
the mic on
thank you
hi thank you my name is Crystal bishop
and I'm a nursing student at the mass
College of Pharmacy and health science I
am reaching out to you with regards to
the house bill 491 relating to prone
Restraint of minors I support the
passing of this bill as it states prone
restraint should be specified in current
Rich rate and seclusion laws ultimately
forbidding its use
prome restraint is one where a miner is
forced face down on the floor and has
pressure applied to their body in order
to keep them in the prone position the
use of prone restraint increases
mortality among children due to the risk
of altered respiratory and cardiac
function when forced pressure is applied
restraining minors should be a last
resort de-escalation and crisis
management strategies should take
precedence over the act of physically
chemically or environmentally
restraining a minor not only does it not
benefit their physical health but it
also compromises their mental health by
increasing trauma-related care if
restraints are necessary for the safety
of the minor or someone around them a
seated restraint should be utilized as a
mother to a seven-year-old boy I have
concerns that the use of prone restraint
is still an option due to the ambiguous
wording of current law with increasing
concern over safety issues in schools
over the past several years program
restraint should not be included in
those concerns as as it is within our
means to Outlaw its use it is my hope
that you will approve this bill to
fibrate the use of prone restraints for
minors
thank you wow it can be done it was done
wonderfully thank you where's your
school located
um we have three campuses but I'm on the
Manchester New Hampshire campus okay
good thank you any questions
okay the alderman from Manchester says
it's the best of the three
laughs
keep the money coming
any questions for the nursing student
how long do you have to go
um we're uh three months April I'm
graduated
congratulations thank you for your
service we need you thank you chair
recognizes Beth morgason
from d c y f g c slash LL do I have all
general counsel okay yes I'm Beth
margeson I'm the general counsel and
legislative liaison for dcyf
um I just am here to provide information
to the committee uh since 2019
dcyf has sent out a uh notice to our
treatment programs uh discouraging the
use of prone restraints uh except for in
times where you can you need to get
control of the person and move them to a
safer restraint and also for purposes of
safely transporting them I'm sorry I
can't really see the people over there
um and uh so we just wanted to provide
that information
um uh to the committee and uh you know
obviously the the division does not run
schools or treatment programs so this is
an annual notification that we make to
our treatment programs so if there's any
other questions I'll be happy to answer
them thank you counselor
the chair recognizes Jennifer Jones from
the office of the child advocate she has
hand outs and she has boiled her
oh excuse me no no that was a mistake on
my part no it's just we're I'm having a
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee I hope to Dazzle you with
an under three minute uh under three
minute testimony as uh the folks behind
me have done such a beautiful job of
narrating
um the support that the office of the
child advocate
um also has in support of this bill
before you today so I am one of two
assistant child Advocates
um and I'm here on behalf of the child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
Cassandra Sanchez who had unavoidable
conflict with being here today
um
so while we largely support again a
testimony that you've already heard one
thing that I think is really important
to impart from our office's perspective
as as we really
um
you know we really are aimed to be a
voice of the children in the state of
New Hampshire is how children actually
feel how Children and Youth actually
feel
um about prone restraint and so I want
to provide an anecdote from a youth that
our office recently had communication
with and this was it was a youth in a
more restrictive placement setting and
was prepared to be stepped down and when
interviewing with different placement
providers this youth expressed
significant concern about whether or not
the providers that they would be
interviewing with would use prone
restraint
and so
um
you know the the child noted that they
understood
um how dangerous this restraint is and
had seen nudist articles
um where children had died as a result
of positional asphyxiation when in prone
position so again
um you know I hope to impart on you the
voice of of children in our community
and what and what youth are thinking
about and being faced with
um you know what we know about children
in residential placement is
um almost all largely have trauma
backgrounds so the idea that
um there's a restraint being used that
can provide that can create additional
trauma is simply unacceptable and I
think our children are saying that as
well
thank you so much you did great you
originally wanted 15 minutes and you
boiled it down so you are in my hall of
fame wonderful any questions
any questions any questions
Mr chairman yes representative Bickford
uh thank you Mr chairman
um your your letter you passed out yes
it seems to cut off is there more that
we should know it says although the
office of child advocate firmly believed
from restraint so you want to take the
first two pages before you hand it out
pass it down there's two pages oh
okay thank you
it's a common mistake
any other questions for either page
saying none thank you so much thank you
so much for having me
I'm going to pronounce that UE as if
it's you omlout
uh would you hold for one minute some
laughs can't be stifled and we want this
one to have its full run
it has page one but no page two and I
have page two but no one we'll have
uh
good morning uh Mr chairman members of
the committee might for the record my
name is Keith kenning I'm the advocacy
director at Waypoint and um we support
um
HP 491 uh with uh representative Muse's
um Amendment
um a representative amuse uh spoke uh
sometime with my CEO borja Alvarez de
Toledo uh borja could not be here today
but he felt like it was so important
that he asked me to publicly testify on
behalf of Waypoint and this is a brief
statement we have House Bill 491
clarifies the intent of RSA chapter 160
126u to ban prone restraint ensure the
safety of children clarifying the
prohibition of prone respraying is
critical not only from a safety
perspective but also from a clinical
perspective
most kids in residential facilities who
find themselves subject to prone
restraint have trauma histories as a
result of trauma children may respond to
triggers with uncontrollable fear and or
aggression
restraints exacerbate this trauma and
impede progress and recovery even the
absence of physical injury prohibiting
prone restraint requires those caring
for our most vulnerable children to
better understand the child's needs and
triggers thereby avoiding the use of
restraint and providing effective care
and treatment so that is Waypoint
statement thank you very much for your
time
any questions
thank you the chair wishes to read into
the record a statement from Michael
padmore from the New Hampshire Medical
Society Mr chairman I just wanted to
send a note ahead of 491 hearing this
morning I will not be able to testify
but I did vet the bill
with our psychiatric and pediatric
Community both are in full support this
text was under three minutes thank you
Mr padmore
um
in consultation with the vice chair and
ranking member
uh I think we're on ahead of steam and
I'd love to pass this excuse me I'd love
to exec this bill while all of you are
here so
um I asked the vice chairman if he would
do a side by side to give us a very
quick overview as to how the amendment
uh changes the bill and I do appreciate
it it's a full text Amendment those are
actually easier so Mr Vice chairman
thank you Mr chairman uh
would it be in order to uh yes it will
on House Bill 491. you uh let me move
the bill uh I move House Bill 491 with
Amendment 112 H as ought to pass is
there a second
buy yes the dynamic duo uh of page one
and page two friends
um now you may go ahead okay thank you
Mr chairman I spoke with the sponsor and
uh statement of findings one two and
three
um in the original Bill uh doesn't
articulate well enough that
that prone restraint restraint is
prohibited so in the amendment that
we're talking about one two and three
clarifies that
and that's
that's one of the changes the other
change is uh on line 27 on the original
Bill appearance of pain
was removed uh for the reason being that
a child who knows the system
can certainly give an appearance a pain
um
and that's mine did that's that's the uh
Amendment
that's what that's what changes in the
amendment from the original bill
in your opinion is it really just a
little bit of clarification it is yeah
and just one other thing I I if I may uh
Mr chairman the the uh what's the the
sponsor told me that dcyf may have
no actually the um there was concerns
because
um you know we often for transporting a
child we will need to restrain them
behind their back however that is done
in a standing up position not in a prone
restraint position I just want to
because thank you so much Ross knows
much more about these things than I do I
just want to make sure because we do we
do need you know the ability to restrain
a child standing up so but it seems fine
now with that I will close the hearing
on House Bill 491 and do what I should
have done a minute ago and open an exec
session on House Bill 491 and the chair
moves ought to pass with amendments
zero one one two H and representative
Perez is seconding it now we can do what
we were doing yeah
I would use the phrase slam dunk but
that could be misinterpreted
representative Raymond I'd just like to
say I don't think more discussion is
warranted that we had a number of
um very
um articulate and
experts who testified in favor of this
bill they explained to us very clearly
what the medical repercussions are of
using this type of restraint and I think
if we keep in mind that our jobs here is
to are to act in the best interests of
children that we will vote this ought to
pass
any further discussion
representative log thank you Mr chairman
uh just a clarification from the clerk
um was it I believe I made a motion on
uh accepting the amendment
and did you get a second
I'll second all right representative
long moves the amendment and
representative D Simone moves seconds
the
Amendment
trying to write and think at the same
seeing no further discussion if the
clerk would call the role on the
amendment 11 well 112 to House Bill 491
moved by representative long seconded by
representative D Simone
the motion is
to accept the amendment but to pass
chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
the amendment passes 16 to zero and now
the motion on the floor is House Bill
491 a moved by representative Pearson
call the question the clerk may call the
roll
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative bigfoid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
ought to pass with Amendment
passes 16-0
any objection to consent the chair will
be honest consent
yeah I I don't know if this should be on
a house floor because it'll bring
awareness that this I mean a consent
it'll just be a quiet pass through
uh so I don't know if we just want to
get a vote on the floor uh the consent's
okay okay I don't want to risk it okay
plus I'm going to write a brilliant
blurb oh
I'll get it in the union later
well I hope so I mean it's just put all
of our names on it
uh represent Mr landrigan in the house
anywhere this one's for you Kevin all
right this closes that I wanted to do
this while you were here and all of you
were here
thank you thank you
that's very helpful thank you
just remember AARP is feeding us let's
the chair is having a brain cramp
and I have four pink cards in front of
me from Don McKinney Bill Woods
Richard head and friend not are Upham if
you filled out a pink card and are not
any of those four people I have managed
to lose it and you can fill out another
one
yeah I don't think I lost hers yet
because I haven't had a chance to okay
open the hearing on House Bill 306
relative to prohibiting reunification
therapy the chair recognizes
representative Fran Nutter Upham
it's to present the Bill thank you Mr
chairman
um so I am Fran Nutter Upham
I have a masters in counseling I have
been a licensed clinical mental health
counselor
um I got my license in 2005. I let it
drop in 15 because I was doing other
work and this morning I turned in the
rest of my papers to get reinstated so I
have
expertise in diagnosing
and treating
um
several different
um well ailments I guess we'll call it
I'm also an art therapist more of you
know of me in in that
um
venue I've worked in private practice
impatient Mental Hospitals
out placement
agencies where we went out into the
community to treat children
um
this bill
it's a little hard to get a handle on
because people are going well what is
reunification therapy it sounds nice
you're trying to reunite people but
apparently it comes
out of someone's work it's not a valid
therapy it is not paid for by insurances
because it is not a valid therapy and it
has something to do with abused children
who have
do not want to see their parent who
abused them and the court ordering that
they have some kind of therapy with that
parent who abused them
because it is not a sanctioned therapy
of course it is not paid for by
insurance so whichever parent
the court would then order to pay for
this therapy it would be out of pocket
and at Great expense
um
I have um
I think the bill needs a little more
work and I think the bill needs buy-in
from several of the agencies legal dcyf
Waypoint that would have expert
knowledge in in dealing with the courts
and dealing with children who have
experienced some of these things so
um
I have a a brief thing I wanted to read
you I know you have received information
and testimony
so um a former a retired lawyer Paula
worm
uh
as a I'm just going to read like two
short paragraphs
she says as a former family law attorney
who concentrated on child abuse and
neglect law I became educated about
systematic structural problems towards
the end of my career impacting the
health and well-being of families in the
child custody and child abuse and
domestic violence cases
this paper is an outgrowth of months of
Hands-On Court
house research I concentrated my efforts
on the complex case docket and other
cases in the Seacoast area
and she has a brief paragraph that she
says reunification therapy
um
it's a reunification therapy is not a
therapy because it isn't covered by
health insurance
and it's not a real therapy it is
unethical for a psychologist
and I would also say psychiatrist or
psychotherapist or a social worker to
participate in it judges are ordering it
to the tune of a hundred thousand
dollars or more and demanding that
protective parents borrow the funds to
pay for it Grandparents of New Hampshire
children have taken out second mortgages
on homes to pay for it
it is one thing to order therapy in a
child abuse or neglect case where the
judge has founded a complaint and there
is a duty under federal law to attempt
to reunify parent and child but to order
reunification therapy when they have the
power to condition
child contact on a parent addressing
their bad behavior is beyond the pale it
is almost exclusively oh all right then
it goes on so
what what I would request from you today
which is maybe a little unusual for
someone introducing a bill is that you
retain this bill so that I can
uh and I'm I'm willing to work on it in
the fall
people have already approached me about
they would like to give their input up
to form a better bill that we can Define
the terms that we need to Define so that
this is a clear Bill and that
we can make an airtight case against
reunification therapy
and and maybe inform the courts about
what is appropriate therapy in this case
if this they felt bearingly perhaps that
this was a tool that was
innocuous or helpful
perhaps they didn't understand it is not
and I'd be happy to take questions or
comments
I think you know from our work in Health
and Human Services together last term
that one of my day jobs is to be
part-time CEO of a medical and
counseling center and one of the things
I ask when I go to hire
potential new councilors to join my
staff is are you licensed
uh are the people who practice
reunification
therapy licensed are they required to be
um her testimony goes on to say that
there are some
social workers that participate in this
which I find a little hard to believe
but so I think if we stick with the line
that you need a light so a licensed
therapist of any kind would not
participate in this form of therapy
because it's not a real form of therapy
and how does one determine what is a
real form of therapy that's an excellent
question
um
if and I have read I have a stack of
papers like this articles about that
whatever so
it could be based on something called
alienation syndrome which apparently is
not listed in the DMS yes yeah I worked
in DSM and I couldn't find it right yeah
so
um if you were to treat a disorder the
disorder would be in the diagnostic
practical manual manual of disorders
right it's our it's our therapy Bible
that we can look everything up it
doesn't go it doesn't give the treatment
that's another book but so to be a valid
disorder it would have to be in the
statistical manual and then to treat
that disorder
you would have to have a real disorder
you can't make one off and then make up
your own therapy
follow-up question there are all kinds
of stuff out there
um somebody comes up with something and
sells it on TV
um
is this reunification therapy
acknowledged by any of the professional
associations uh of Psychiatry or
psychology nationally
as a valid therapy as a valid therapist
I believe not okay
okay any further questions for the Prime
sponsor
I don't see any and you your testimony
included the statement that there were
people who would like to work with you
they don't have to wait until the fall
um any citizen can work with you further
if you wish
um you mentioned that so it is your hope
that this committee would retain the
bill for further work right because it
um with the support of this committee to
name a time in a place where we could
meet
um and notice that we were meeting we
may get some shareholders in that we
might I might not otherwise know how to
contact my the what you you will recall
the way I worked at Health and Human
Services committee was any group of
people with a couple of reps you know
we're not going to violate 91a we're not
going to have 51 percent of the
committee but we could grab a couple of
reps and then anybody from the
Department from this Association that
whatever and spend a lot of time hanging
out doing things so that when we come to
the fall and take a retained bill off
the table and look at it again a lot of
work has been done prior to that I am
more than willing to facilitate what
worked as you recall we didn't do work
groups in the traditional way we did
them a different way and I think it had
some success I believe so okay thank you
see no
further except for one except for one
representative representative ball
thank you chairman
just a point of clarification for me
because I'm taking the notes
um the alienation syndrome did you said
that is not in the DSM it is not okay
that's I just wanted to make sure I had
that correct thank you thank you
representative
Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um so is reunification therapy being
ordered in the state of New Hampshire it
is so what do they do is it's just
psychotherapy
Well it can't be Psychotherapy because
it would be illegal they have to be
doing something if it's ordered so what
are they doing for therapy
um it's non-licensed people who are
doing and I'd like more information
about what exactly so it's it can't be a
licensed person because it wouldn't be
covered by insurance and it wouldn't be
ethical for their discipline
to engage in therapy that is not a valid
therapy so it would have to be
somebody who says I do reunification
therapy without
I don't know what kind of training
okay so you're not sure how they're
currently treating it but we but we know
that it's being ordered yes okay thank
you thank you representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
to take the word reunification out
and just
um
state that the family needed to enter
into therapy
could it be during that therapeutic time
that the therapist would gear couldn't
it be true that the therapist would gear
toward
reunifying the family unit
without using the reunification
and um
I think it's appropriate sometimes for
courts to say I think we need a therapy
to see what we can do with this family I
would just be comfortable that it's a
licensed therapist therapist who's
working to
I wish I could find an uh to put the
family back together if that's possible
but the reunification therapy is always
with a case of abuse
and like how far do you push a child to
have to be in the presence of someone
who abused them I mean I quit a job a
few years ago over a salary dispute and
I never want to see my manager again
and I'm you know and that's trivial
compared to what some of these children
would have been through and so
um
I
I'm kind of pollyanna-ish I'd like to
think that professional licensed
therapists would do whatever is in the
best interest of the child
and not to have the court order we want
type a therapy
just the the blanket
this family needs therapy that's
appropriate but to pick which kind and
who they need to go to and how to pay
out of pocket is not appropriate as we
did past House Bill 200
about Judges ordering therapy has to be
within a parent's insurance plan and and
that's fair so
yeah we're not ready to put microphones
inside of the therapy offices to know
exactly the nuances of everything that
goes on but I like to trust in my
profession that
qualified licensed therapists are are
doing a good job I'd like to also think
that judges are honest in doing their
best job but maybe in this case maybe a
little misinformed about what's going on
seeing no further questions thank you
representative for introducing your bill
I now have a handful of pink cards
roughly divided pro and con and for
everyone now we are under our
three-minute rule if you have a story to
tell give the highlights if you have
papers to give to us please uh present
them over in the corner before you come
up
and I'd like to Now call upon Don
McKenney from the Hampshire legal
assistance
foreign
the policy director at New Hampshire
legal assistance
um
you're going to hear from much more
expert folks after me I believe but
um we support the idea of retaining the
bill and and working on another
um some additional revisions or language
we
do not
um support reunification therapy uh we
think though that this bill also would
not prevent the use of unification
therapy as currently drafted so we're
interested in working on with the
sponsor on
um Drafting and clarifying some of the
language uh and getting buy-in from the
courts Etc to make sure that it can be
implemented
foreign
the chair recognizes it looks like Bill
Woolsey that's what I can read if that's
different let me know
my handwriting is bad
I got bill
yes
sir
good afternoon members of the committee
thank you very much for uh allowing me
to speak today my name is Bill Woodbury
oh
this doesn't count against Japan okay
Okay so
my name is Bill Woodbury and I'm a an
attorney practicing in Laconia
practicing primarily family law and
although I do do other things
and I am the uh I'm a past president and
current legislative chair for New
Hampshire Association for justice and uh
we're here in um in opposition to this
bill
we believe that where it is our job to
kind of look out for things that deny
access to justice that this is an issue
of that of that nature in that it is
taking away an important tool in the
judicial toolbox
and I don't know that I mean in the 19
years that I've been doing family law I
have not seen the reunification Theory
as presented occurring
um so I'm not saying it isn't I practice
in a specific part of the state but I
think that um what the what the prime
sponsor said is absolutely true that
there needs to be a more specific
definition of what is being discussed
here I think it was representative de
Simone that kind of hit upon the fact
that there's any number of things that
could be ordered by the court that could
fall into the the the
umbrella of reunification therapy
um is any number of situations a vast
number of situations and different types
of cases abuse neglect divorce
post-divorce where um you know uh the
court could see it as uh in the best
interest of the child as is their
mandate they there it is under um 461a
is the policy of the state to ensure
that both parents have
um a relationship in contact with the
with the child as long as it's in that
child's best interest
so I think that in the absence of a firm
definition of what constitutes
reunification therapy uh that and the
fact that
um as to the to the other parts of this
that
um the judges I think always try to make
sure that there's ability to pay
insurance
agreement between the parties as to who
is going to be approached for therapy in
my experience the judges go a long way
to try and make sure that they're not
going to order something that's
impossible
um you know that would be against their
mandate as well they're not going to
order something that somebody simply
can't do financially or otherwise so I
think this bill uh it it it's kind of
asking for something that's exceedingly
vague right now and that we do we oppose
it I'm happy to answer any questions
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my call I wonder if you could
please provide a couple of you know
General examples of
um situations family situations where
reunification therapy would be have been
administered
well again not knowing the exact
definition that that the prime sponsor
described or that you know if something
costing hundreds of thousands of dollars
or anything like that but the need to
have therapy to promote reunification
could happen after a period of of a
parent being in prison uh could happen
after a period of a parent being in
rehab for substance abuse it could have
no absolutely nothing to do with abuse
or anything like that it could happen
after there was a finding of abuse
um and you know uh with with therapy
that parent proves to the court that
they they have the ability to go forward
with a relationship with a child that is
all right
um
there are any number of situations you
know that you could imagine with as an
interruption in that relationship
between a parent and child for whatever
reason and the Court's always going to
going to be asking the question the
first instance is it in the best
interest of the child to reunify with
this parent
um and if it is not they'll they'll be
you know an alternative solution
suggested but therapy is a crucial Tool
uh and again many things would fall
under that umbrella of reunification
therapy
saying none thank you thank you for
the chair recognizes
it's either John dejoy or it does your
way
well it could be it's French from the
National Association of Social Workers
in New Hampshire Psychological
Association
how do you pronounce it dejoy welcome to
America
many generations ago I'm sure
many generations ago Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you very much for
your time
my clients the New Hampshire Association
uh
the National Association of Social
Workers is a nationwide
yeah
Nationwide membership group for social
workers across the country I represent
the New Hampshire chapter which has more
than 700 members uh with all social
workers in New Hampshire New Hampshire
Psychological Association similarly is a
National Organization I represent the
New Hampshire chapter which works with
New Hampshire doctoral level and school
psychologists neither of my clients have
a position on this bill I had no
intention of testifying
I'd just like to provide a little bit of
context regarding what is referred to as
reunification therapy I think what the
sponsor was trying to say at the
beginning and not to put words in her
mouth this is not an evidence-based
practice
evidence-based practice is the gold
standard of any kind of therapeutic
intervention what re what a therapy what
an evidence-based practice is requires
is research
that confirms the efficacy
and the outcomes of any intervention
reunification therapy broadly is not an
accepted intervention by any national
mental health or psychological
organization
it has in fact been researched since the
mid 80s was originally referred to as
parental alienation syndrome
it is now simply recall referred to as
parental alienation it is not a syndrome
officially
it is also not in the DSM-5 which is the
diagnostic and statistical manual for
mental illness that is used by most um
psychotherapists
is
when it's been ordered it's been ordered
relative to divorce disputes where one
parent has accused another parent of
saying bad things my word and alienating
that child from the parent
our the position of both of my clients
very simply is that there is no such
thing as reunification therapy
um
and with due respect to the court we
respect the Court's need for assessments
and therapeutic intervention and think
that's appropriate in any instance that
the judge believes it's appropriate
however
my clients do not believe a judge should
be ordering reunification therapy
any more than they should order CBT DBT
psychoanalysis or any other
evidence-based practice if a judge has a
need for an assessment that is an
appropriate order
and they may even order the therapist to
assess the ability of the family to
reunify
that's appropriate
it's also appropriate to provide
therapeutic intervention
in that case though licensed therapists
in all instances take their lead from
what the clients whether that's an
individual or family what the clients
seek to achieve
if a client seeks to reunify their
family
that can be an appropriate therapeutic
approach
if everyone in the family is in
agreement
so with that I'll leave it at that but
we just simply wanted to provide context
that this is not a recognized practice
nor is an Evidence evidence-based
practice and we would strongly request
with all due respect of the court to
order an assessment or therapy as
opposed to identify the intervention and
permit the licensed therapist to
determine which is the most appropriate
intervention given the needs of that
family
thank you so much uh sir you mentioned
that uh something was studied in the 80s
you use the term parental alienation was
reunification therapy itself ever
studied by outside groups looking at it
it has been studied intermittently in
the literature when I reference parental
alienation syndrome that was the and I
don't have I apologize I do not have the
researcher's name
reunification therapy was a direct
outgrowth of Parental alienation
syndrome and this researcher theorized
that therapy to reunify the family was a
way to address parental alienation
syndrome
since 1980 however many decades that is
my math is not is failing me today since
that there have been intermittent
efforts but most of the literature
suggests it talks about what I spoke
about today that reunification therapy
is not a recognized therapy nor is it
evidence-based some researchers refer to
it as pseudoscience others simply say it
is not it doesn't have a body of
knowledge that recognizes the efficacy
or the positive outcomes of the of any
in intervention of that sort thank you
any further questions from Mr dejoy uh
representative Raymond
um thank you and thank you um Mr dejoy
for taking my question
um you had said that your clients um
which are a psychological Association
nationally and the New Hampshire chapter
and then the Association of Social
Workers nationally and the New Hampshire
chapter would ask judges to order an
assessment and therapy if appropriate
um would you want would your clients
also want that to say like buy a
licensed mental health counselor
or mental health counselor licensed by
the state of New Hampshire or something
there to indicate that it is in fact
someone who has been licensed and is
overseen as opposed to just any person
calling themselves a counselor
thank you very much for the question
representative and just for clarity I
represent the New Hampshire chapters of
both organizations okay there is a
National Organization as well that I do
not represent okay thank you for
clarifying so
I have not had that conversation with my
client uh directly
and I'm losing my train of thought
can you repeat the question just that's
okay my question was instead of ordering
a particular type of counseling or
therapy
would your associations want judges to
or even have a law that said judges are
are to order
um you know assessment and appropriate
therapy by a licensed you know counselor
or mental health therapist that's a
great question we we believe that um
we believe that interventions of that
level
ought to be licensed but we have a
license licensing scheme in this state
that requires social workers identifying
themselves in certain ways to be
licensed as well as psychologists to be
licensed
I'll leave that to to you folks in Edna
um
I would hope that the court and I
believe the courts are using due
diligence as the if they assign someone
to assess and that they are using
licensed therapists I don't know that
but that would be my expectation
thank you
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman uh the researcher you spoke of
in 1980s uh on alienation was that Dr
Richard Gardner
I can find out representative and get
back to you John what I know of that
it probably is then but I don't have the
name but I'd be happy to get it and send
it to you we'll send it to the whole
committee if you'd if you'd like thank
you
thank you sir thank you
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
foreign
copies of what I'm handing out if not I
um
and I'm happy to to begin
um the record my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um what I'm handing out is a written
testimony from Judge Jennifer Lemire who
apologizes was unable to make it today
she had to be on the bench um if you
don't have enough copies I do have some
extras
um I can give I can hand out
um in what is contained in judgments
um testimony is is sort of in very
general terms what it is and how she
uses
um counseling which uh is broadly
described as reunification counseling
um
at the end of the day we do support
having this bill retained we think as
written it is very Broad and could
Encompass a great deal more than perhaps
even one than what was intended uh in
terms of the of the scope of it
um and and in general you know as the
the sponsor had identified uh
reunification therapy is being used in
abusive abuse and neglect situations and
the reality is it is uh considered in a
much broader Circle set of circumstances
where
um there's been a long period of
separation between a parent and a child
uh whether it be by imprisonment by some
mental health issues that have have
caused a parent not to participate uh
with a child whether it be
um
a whole host of potential reasons why
there's been a period of separation
between a parent and a child and and
that child may very well have no memory
of that parent or have no impression of
that parent and have no interest in
having that parent participate in their
in their lives and the reality is though
as as a judge they have constitutional
and statutory obligations relative to
both parents having a role in that child
in that child's life
and as as judge Lemire explains in her
written testimony
during the course of of a proceeding she
may not have or a judge may not have
sufficient information to know what is
the cause of the child's resistance to a
parent in in what is driving that and
whether or not it is abuse and and and
fear which is legitimate and and has to
be accounted for in terms of whether
that parent does have a role but also
just is it time that is has led that
person that child to have no interest in
a in a relationship is it another parent
that is causing uh information to go to
that child that is causing that child to
resist wanting the other parent involved
and as she describes her testimony when
she believes that that
additional counseling is is appropriate
and necessary given the lack of sort of
information available to her and she's
ordering counseling she does not simply
order reunification therapy she talks to
the parties about it because there has
to be buy-in from the parties in
identifying the counselor she will ask
the frequently the the counselor is
already involved don't have either the
skill or the interest in bringing in
what is necessary for this type of of
counseling which is both parents the
child and working with them as a group
at times so she does ask the parents to
solicit
recommendations of who could be the the
counselor and reunification setting uh
she can she would take those names if
they infrequently the parties agree to
who would be that counselor if they
don't she asks for names that would come
from sources preferably from existing
counselors already involved in a in uh
counseling the parties whether it be the
parents or the child
but at the end of the day
what is concerning about the bill is its
breadth would eliminate all sort of
counseling and therapy that relates to
the the the reunification of of a child
who is resisting uh a particular parent
for a reason that may not be abuse it
may be a time it may be whatever it may
be there's there's just almost an
unlimited number of fact circumstances
that can lead a child to resist and uh
and if the if there is an opportunity to
bring that family unit together and and
at least in the as judge Lemire points
out it has been successful in in cases
it is a tool that is available and we
look we we feel that simply eliminating
an entire category without more detail
and specifics can lead to some
unintended consequences so we do support
we would be happy to participate with
the with the chair whether it be in a a
retained Committee hearing or just with
the sponsor and the parties to to work
through exactly what is intended what is
the the aspect of this that
there's opposition and where in fact it
can be useful
so we oppose the bills written we would
be happy to participate if the bill is
retained it is a bill that seems to come
up every year uh and fail every year so
if there's a specific aspect of this
that is uh the target then you know we'd
be happy to work with the committee and
the sponsor to try to identify that but
at least as written it would eliminate a
tool that does get used and has been
used successfully in the court system it
is an area I will confess I'm not at all
an expert in so if you have questions
I'd be happy to try to answer them but I
may have to defer but with that I'll
conclude my comments but I'd be happy to
attempt to answer anything now this is
representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman uh attorney head
on the document passed out from Judge
Lemire on page four it refers in the
third paragraph down of um to allow
the entities to participate in
counseling
and then it refers to a colleague's
calling it reunification therapy has
already heard that reunification therapy
does not exist
as a professional designation
with the
the elimination of that in the in the
review of the bill makes make this in a
more appropriate Act
so I think the real question is whatever
we call it we have to ident we have to
explain what that is and and that's why
you'll see in judge lemire's letter
reunification therapy being used in
quotes and and and and the reality is as
she said she wasn't sure what the scope
was of of the intent of the bill and in
that kind of ambiguity we may lose an
important tool that in fact people agree
is useful so I I and I may not have
answered a question but but I'm not sure
just changing the word would be would
would cure the potential issue
I'm going to follow up Mr chairman yes
follow-up thank you sir uh attorney then
specific to the bill and I'm in favor of
retaining uh this was where it states on
line five uh was recommended by parties
and if that a participating provider in
the party's health insurance carrier
it's the next sentence that's caused a
concern and that's the identifier of
reunification therapy again as an entity
what would be your guidance
on that so um so thank you for the
question I think there are instances
where
you can have it a counselor recommended
by the parties and they're not
participating a participating provider
but the parties are willing and have the
ability to pay
um and as as judge Lemire said you know
insurance if there is Insurance that's
obviously the best but there are
instances where there is not
Insurance available for whatever reason
but the parties have a willingness and
an ability to pay and the ability to pay
is a a part of her evaluation and and
the parties do not have that ability to
pay she does not order it and she has
financial statements she has information
available to her to make that
determination so
I would say simply saying all all
Counseling Services have to be covered
by a in insurance and that provider has
to be covered by the insurance may be
too restrictive if you make it a flat
obligation
okay thank you sir thank you Mr chairman
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you attorney head for
coming and answering our questions
um it seems to me that there is
um some tension and conflict between
different parties using the same phrase
to mean different things so it sounds
like judges are using reunification
therapy as kind of a catch-all
generic term referring to any a various
list of modalities of therapy that could
lead to a family reunifying which is the
Mandate frankly in a dcyf case you know
as we move through there's a mandate to
try and reunify within 12 months so I
guess my question is then
um now that we are learning through this
process that there is something that is
um a questionable practice called
reunification therapy is it possible to
have
um like advice or a Judicial note or
guidelines for our judges to not use
that term because it is so easily
confused with a treatment modality that
is not evidence-based and instead asks
judges to refrain from using the term
reunification therapy and use instead
something that is
um more clinically appropriate such as
assessment and therapeutic intervention
if warranted or I don't I'm not an
attorney so you know crafting that would
be better but to to consciously have
judge consciously avoid using a term
that is also the name of a very specific
non-evidence-based treatment modality
just like they wouldn't order you know
CBC therapy or you know dialectic
behavioral therapy because that's not in
their purview
I'm so thank you for the question I
think
in part the answer is yes
um but in part the the concern would
still be if
a a bill is passed that prohibits quote
unquote reunification therapy without
defining that the scope of that could
include
anything that that where where the
reunification of the parties is I mean
it's such a basic word and doesn't seem
to have a a certainly within the bill a
definition of what is being included in
that term
um that even if we did go ahead and have
guidance and and
a process where the term reunification
therapy was not used it may still be
considered within the scope of that if
if we have a flat out legislative
prohibition on on this type of of
counseling
thank you
so and again that just leads to I given
that this is a bill that comes up on
right with a on a regular basis
it would help to retain it and see if
there is a way of of putting that you
know those two pieces as you described
together that that don't conflict with
thank you counselor thank you
the chair recognizes Gail drobat
yes I just want to take a moment and
apologize to all the members of the
committee and people on the public if
you see me like
sitting and walking away and all that I
I have someone who is
it was very close and
um into my heart it was someone who
um
it was like
um my supporter
person when I moved here
pass away last night oh we're sorry
we're sorry
um and um
it's been one of those toughest day that
uh I wish I can be in Virginia
with my extended family but
um I'm grateful to be here and yeah and
I'm so sorry that I'm like walking back
and forth but I just started like
Take It All In
do whatever you need representative
thank you you asked for one minute and
we're getting overtime so we'll give you
one minute I need more than that well
we'll give you three and then the mic
disappears you might need more than that
too uh well you're not gonna get it
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um for letting me testify
today my name is Gail drobat I'm from
Amherst New Hampshire
I am a mom that has never been involved
in the family court but
this has come up a lot with the
reunification from parents I've talked
to
I'm going to talk about one specific
case without any names
um
and I'm going to give you this
the family was ordered
to have the child engage with an
individual therapist for the child to
speak about his feelings
the therapist allowed mom in that those
sessions
gave dad minimal information
she said she saw him twice
and told Dad that it would take several
more sessions for him to be comfortable
to open up and then she wrote a bad
she recommended a reunification
therapist two doors down in her same
building
so you can imagine dad's reluctance
once asked what he would do to assess
diagnose and treat this situation
so this child hasn't seen his father in
five years or any other member of his
father's family
so the court orders another
reunification therapist
recommended by a long-standing bar
member who they won't release the name
of
he contacted her on November 2nd no
response November 19th no response
December 20th
she said in response to your inquiry
about reunification counseling I am
attaching my copy of my service
agreement
and get back to me
January 21st 2022 he says
when's the soonest you can see us
January 24th to this the extent I
received from un the other party I
unfortunately do not accept expect to
have any availability for several months
after she told the court she would take
then again on April 22nd he said my son
and I were court ordered to engage with
you
no response
the parties go to court
mom has been in contact with the
therapist
ah
he contacts her again on April 10th
again my son and I with the court
therapy
on April 14th she says I received your
email regarding court ordered family
therapy unfortunately my practice is
full
five years this child has not seen his
father
and for the court to keep going this
and dad has made multiple motions to
have it referred to other therapists
denied denied denied
so
my request to you all and we just heard
that reunification isn't a therapy
you've got half a minute I'm going to
give you this after so
I think court ordered therapy involved
in family court systems need to be done
with a clinical psychologist with a
minimal of family systems therapy to
figure out the breakdown of the family
these kids cannot go weeks months years
without seeing both parents if there is
an attachment pathology you better get
it fixed quickly because you're ruining
the lives of these children may we ask
you a question you sure can my question
is this if there was a licensed in the
state of New Hampshire therapist of some
type and this push push push and ignore
ignore ignore took place there is a
board where a complaint may be filed
where is the board for UNIF unification
therapy the Mental Health Board
and a complaint was filed and there was
no wrongdoing found
there was a complaint to The JCC no
wrongdoing found there was a complaint
to the attorney discipline office no
finding
and we'll talk about that on another
bill but
um
I think we really need to sit down with
all parties and the Judiciary and figure
out something for these kids because at
the end of the day the kids are the ones
being abused and it's got to stop
they're our future does anyone else have
any questions besides me representative
Petrino thank you chairman and thank you
for taking my question I'm just a little
bit confused so I just need some
clarification sure the bill we're
looking at prohibits the use of
reunification therapy but the situation
that you explained was that this
individual was trying to get
reunification therapy for five years or
more awarded by the courts and could not
make this happen right so I'm just
confused it sounds like
reunification therapy was something that
was welcomed but this bill says that we
should prohibit it and that's where I'm
confused the court ordered it
I think it should be prohibited it
doesn't
address
um well it's a non-established therapy
first off so they need to address the um
why the parent the child has an
attachment pathology why is a rejection
apparent
you know and that should be done
immediately if they're going into family
court and a child's rejecting a parent
you better find out why quickly because
either
the parent that has the child is abusing
them psychologically and keeping them
away from one parent or the other parent
has abused them so either way
you better do something quick and this
thank you for your question
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls Kathy Jones
from Plaistow I used to represent plasto
for six years mother Justice Network I'm
intrigued about that since it was in my
district at one point well thank you
um and thank you for having me here
today oh excuse me uh with the previous
uh do what she's doing hand in her
written testimony thank you sorry it's
okay
um so thank you for allowing me to be
here today I do have written testimony
but every time I hear somebody else say
something my the thoughts of my head
change so I'm going to do this as best
as I can as quickly as I can my name is
Kathy Jones I'm with Mother Justice
Network I do not have a string of
letters after my name but I have 25
years in the business of domestic
violence and been a national expert on
domestic violence and the reason I'm
here today is because high conflict
family court cases is equal to domestic
violence related cases they are one in
the same and in a vast majority of these
type of cases that end up in Family
Court which is different from Child
Protection court and I understand that
child protection has its uses for
reunification but I'm specifically here
to talk about family court and
reunification therapies today
um
there is so much damage being done
across the state by courts who are
ordering children to be forced into
reunification therapies with parents who
are abusive not only to the children
themselves but also to their former
intimate partner which is creating just
both for the families and individually
but for the court systems themselves who
are overwhelmed by these high conflict
cases that keep coming back in coming
back in coming back in because there is
no end in sight
divorce is a industry it's a 50 billion
dollar industry in the country and
reunification therapy I feel like is
responsible for at least half of it
there is no regulation it practitioners
can charge whatever the heck they want
it's all out of pocket paid and this is
money that should be going for better
things like child support and actually
helping the individuals and the families
involved
in 2018 and 2019
I I don't know I'm sorry I forgot to say
I'm a completely unfunded program by the
way and my entire life is devoted to
protective parents who are trying to
keep their children safe through the
family court system you've got one
minute okay in 2018 and 2019 I'd put
together a support group for protective
parents who are trying to deal with the
fact that their children were becoming
suicidal because of their reunification
therapies that they were being forced
into these reunification therapists were
denying their children's experiences
were threatening the children were
basically bullying these children into
having contact with family members that
frightened these children
right now I'm dealing with a mother if
somewhere midpoint in our state whose ex
was actually convicted of and spent time
in jail for raping her and she has been
recently notified that the judge in her
case is going to be forcing her children
into reunification therapy with the
father even though he admitted in Family
yes ma'am
and this is the type of stuff that I
deal with day in and day out I am
exhausted by being a one-person
practitioner who is dealing with the
the dregs of what happens when these
family courts systems get this issue
wrong thank you for your testimony I
will
um ask if anyone has any questions
in which
case thank you for your testimony
you'll have 30 seconds then that's
the reason there's a difference between
dcyf and family court is because dcyf as
imperfect as that system may be they
have experts in domestic violence that
are embedded within their systems that
could at least consult with them and
give them guidance as what to do the
family courts do not utilize such
experts and mental health practitioners
and any other professional out there are
not experts in domestic and Family
Violence thank you so much a key problem
thank you so much now we have one more
and this will be the last card I will
receive on this and this is Betty gay
and you will be held to strict three
minutes
foreign
for someone from Houston you can talk
quick
representative gay is late of this
committee and had represented uh plasto
and Atkinson for a while representative
gay
turn it on thank you okay okay to be
fast I made some points how
reunification therapy gets ordered
person files for divorce and alleges
domestic violence they automatically are
referred to high conflict Court
gals are assigned to the children the
parents do not get to choose the gals
the gal asks the children if they want
to be with both parents this assessment
can take all of 15 minutes
the GAO recommends the children be
ordered to reunification therapy with or
without the parent that they don't want
to see if the children are reluctant to
see one of the parents
the parents have no choice of the
counselor
the parent is told that if they don't
take the children that parent will lose
custody it is a absolute threat
the parent takes the child
they pay 100
150 an hour to anywhere as high as 350
an hour
there's no assessment of charge there's
no assessment of Cause part of
reunification therapy as you will see in
this notice of an email from a physician
from an attorney family attorney
mentioning the training for the
attorneys our attorneys here get this
training and they are taught that this
is greater than sliced bread
the parent takes the child there's no
assessment a cause the child has been
that has been subjected to threats
by the counselor by the reach
reunification therapy counselor the
child is told if you don't get with the
program we are going to make you live
with this parent you don't want to be
with
I'm sure there's more to that but that's
a good basic okay the uh what I just
referred in a minute and 15.
okay
um you will see on this letter uh that
as you can see special attention is
given to ensuring the child in question
this is training for attorneys as you
can see in RT the child in question is
not given an F opportunity to validate
his or her fears of the allegedly
abusive parent nor to express grievances
against that parent I know this lawyer
who wrote it is aware of published
critiques of approaches to such cases
based on past and its Affiliated
theories possibly my own work but it's
nevertheless confidently telling lawyers
to ignore the child's perspective
so there therein lies the absolute
cruelty of this practice it doesn't
matter what the child feels but so many
people are making their livings on this
whole system to change it it's like
digging out a mountain with a tablespoon
but I have confidence that there are so
many caring people here that we can
start turning this around
thank you representative do you have a
handouts you'd like us to read my plan
is to exec this bill on the 21st two
weeks from today
foreign
[Music]
um we received some documents here and
it's uh this is me speaking now I'm not
likely to take them seriously they're
not identified as to who they came from
and that is probably just an oversight
on your part
um in a minute here between in the break
between this bill and the next one if
you could sign in that would really make
so with that I am closing the hearing on
House Bill 306 and if a group of you
want to get together over the summer and
work on this and eventually we will take
it off the table that's fine my
suggestion to you as it is to everyone
when assertions are made
I want to see footnotes I want to see
documentation is if there are people who
said that I would like to the degree
that they are willing to give their
names which adds to their credibility we
would do that
um yeah they put themselves at a bit of
a risk to do that but I want to be able
to take them seriously and if there's
cases of we spent a hundred thousand
prove your case is what I'm saying at
prove find a good balanced position
Define your terms prove your case so
then when it comes back here in the fall
we'll have something more substantial to
work on so thank you so much
all right we're going to take about a
five minute uh recess while we regroup
and all these nice papers that
representative gay has given us are duly
also this is for the committee uh the uh
the email the printout that attorney had
to hand it out has a typo on the front
that may confuse you this is House Bill
306 not 603 603 is where we live 306 is
the bill change it so it doesn't get
misfiled
um as a friend of mine says he's not
dyslexic he's less dxic
I'm just wondering are we executing any
other bills today
laptop
opening the hearing on House Bill 490
and act relative to modifying the
definition of neglect the chair
recognizes representative Corcoran to
present his bill
in the form of
the chair recognizes the alderman from
Manchester the vice chairman and ranking
member of this committee The Honorable
Patrick long
thank you Mr chairman
uh
yeah I'll introduce House Bill 490
relative to modifying the definition of
neglect
this never happened in Health and Human
Services
[Music]
here
representative Moulton are you
multitasking by reading the bill while
talking with your friends yes I am
very good at multitasking that's all I
wanted was a straight answer
classroom teacher huh yes as I said
earlier today this is the Rowdy section
I'm disappointed it was my intent to
I'm going back to health and human
services if you
insist on being so serious
I thank you
[Laughter]
foreign
okay let's turn our fun to the bill in
front of us over there our s
Rowdy section
and what do you think about the bill
representative Greg what do you think
about the bill
after you've turned your mic on
all right here I was thinking I wasn't
Rowdy and I'm like full-on Rowdy called
out
um you were not called out you were
selected
that sounds so much better
uh
so I actually I I think this I just
think the language
um we're just discussing right point of
order uh should we do have somebody
signed up to speak on the bill so prior
to discussion oh this is true
somebody speak
I do have a card I have a card
she's so patient over the the chair
recognizes from d c y f e s q
that's Murchison
who actually has been sitting there
waiting for sanity to break out
all kidding aside thank you Mr chair
Vice chair and other members of the
committee so
um the division
um it appreciates the opportunity to
speak on this bill in general the
division is not in favor of modifying
the definition of neglect uh neglect is
a very fact-specific case specific
situation and the enumeration of sort of
activities under this this legislation
would make that very very complicated
for the division that said
um you know we we generally sort of
review this suggested language change as
sort of the free-range child kind of
provision
um and in general I mean the division
does not file for neglect on free-range
children so we just wanted to appreciate
the opportunity to share our thoughts
with the committee on this Bill thank
you I'm happy to take any questions if
anyone has any
would you define free-range child
you know when you see one right
[Laughter]
if it walks like a duck quacks like a
duck no uh you know free range child is
is one who's given a certain amount of
independence by their parents
um depending on their maturity and and
um their uh their sort of capabilities
um I think New Hampshire has a sort of a
night I mean I'm from New Jersey and I
think New Hampshire has a nice sort of
um tradition of that and I think it
makes for healthy this is me talking so
but I think that it does make for
healthy development for children that's
generally what I think of as a
free-range child yeah follow-up question
um would you see this bill a solution
looking for a problem is there a problem
of uh inhibited
pre-range children
no the division would say that we don't
have a problem with that
so you don't follow up to myself you
don't see that there's there's a bunch
of kids that are really being trapped
that could be able to walk to school
because they're 17 or things like that
or drive to school because they're 17. I
I don't know I I don't know Mr chair to
be completely honest well that's what I
want yeah I I yeah I don't we don't I
don't think we see children who are not
you know allowed to do things that are
developmentally appropriate and so but
again I I really have no data on that so
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for speaking to us about this one
um I know that other states have minimum
ages
um for kids to do some of these things
like Illinois for example wants kids to
be like 13 before they're allowed to
stay home alone does New Hampshire have
any guidelines regarding ages for kids
to stay home alone one and two when dcyf
receives a report of say an unintended
child what does the caseworker usually
assess for when deciding whether or not
it meets the statute I I'm not aware
that New Hampshire has minimum wages for
anything taking your first question uh
first uh as to the second question if we
had if there was an assessment for an
unattended child we would certainly look
to the age the maturity the
circumstances was the child left is the
child 12 left in a car while the parent
ran in to get milk or something and the
representative Levesque
do you
potentially see a problem with
it being so vague on uh line 19 into 20
where it says remaining in a vehicle
unattended especially when we've seen
like increases of
over social media of people frantically
trying to save children on hot Vehicles
during the summer trying to break into
them police trying to break into
Vehicles do you see a problem with that
I I think in general the language is
problematic although well-intended I
think just because
um again our our investigations are so
fact and case specific
um uh you know I think that if for some
reason this was in our neglect statute
we would certainly again look to what
representative Raymond said we would
look to the circumstances uh uh
surrounding the child remaining
unattended in the in the uh in the
vehicle
I don't know if that addresses your
question so
no question
you just
representative Bickford uh thank you Mr
chairman
um I see this is more as language that
parents are looking for to give them
guidance as to what they may or may not
do right now they're in kind of a flux
as to when they can leave their child
unattended or go for a ride on the
bicycle and such I I know times have
changed somewhat
I know uh I know when I was a kid which
is just a little while ago
I uh we we thought I think of jumping on
our bicycles at you know nine years old
and going a mile down the road because I
lived in a rural area or two miles down
the road to visit a friend
but today you don't see too much of that
uh anymore I I know my favorite show is
uh Mary Berry RFD one of my favorite
shows anyway and you see Opie going off
and doing things with his with his
friends and
and uh so I think parents are looking
for some Direction
and this might be something that might
be helpful in that that way
I I don't know uh sorry I I can't I
can't presume to speak for parents in
New Hampshire so uh you know I mean we
we sort of I mean there was uh there's a
scene in the movie E.T about Elliot
being left home alone when he was nine
years old and so we were discussing this
like you know is that really problematic
you know it's the E.T Elliott kind of
question but um you know I think that
it's it's up to parents discretion
um and but I again I I just cannot speak
to what parents need in terms of uh
Direction I saw the movie Home Alone
yeah well that probably would be
problematic
so that was a mistake so little children
going to the fishing hole as in Mayberry
RFD is anybody asserting we have an OP
crisis in this state
anyone else yeah
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman and
I wish that the representative who
presented who offered up this bill would
be here to answer questions because I'm
confused about
related to
spiritual means Church good faith I mean
that that is that's current law that is
yeah
all right thank you
this side of the room take take note of
this okay all right thank you
representative ball
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question
um in reading this myself as a person
who apparently is a free-range child
um or was raised a free-range child it
seems to be a societal change because
when I look at these activities this is
exactly what I did when I was eight nine
ten years old and it was always my
understanding and correct me if I'm
wrong please this would be my question
um is that age seven is the Age of
Reason which is why we allow children to
walk to school when they're seven in the
and there's also statue there are also
guidelines for um babysitting as to when
you can leave your child
um home alone and when they can take
care of another person's child so there
are statues but yes that's why children
are not all bossed we do have walkers
that go to elementary school
anyone else
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much in consultation with the vice
chairman
slash ranking member
we are wondering
if we are ready
think so everybody think we've all come
to a conclusion pretty much and it's the
same conclusion
uh we're getting good at this one you
know
so I will close the hearing on House
Bill 490 and open the exact session on
House Bill 490 and the chair is looking
representative Grossman I withdraw my
previous comment it does not have to be
in German when you write the blurb
I mean I'll make a motion
um for uh to move 490 itl 490 itl moved
by representative Grossman who is the
second representative Nelson we will
discussion
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chair
um it seems I was a free-range parent
and when my children got
old enough I actually called the state
and said if I let my child do this at
this age
and this not at that age
am I neglecting my children and they
said I was told and I don't remember who
it was
um if you as a parent feel that your
child children can make those choices
and are mature enough then you as a
parent make that choice now the only one
I ever had
so my children were
on the weekends
yet they were allowed
after they got offing and did their
chores and had their breakfast go
outside and play and don't come back to
lunch
and then at lunch if they weren't fed
outside they were fed inside go outside
and play and don't come back until the
street lights were on come on and the
only one that ever said anything about
that was my granddaughter who said Nan
you was so harsh foreign
but
I I never had an issue with being
charged with neglect or whatever my I I
kind of knew where my kids were
um they were right in town and they did
ride their bikes maybe a mile or
whatever i i s I agree that this is a
bill it's looking for a problem and
there
parent most parents can make educated
choices depending upon their child
now I should not have been left to run
free but my children were just fine
representative Levesque
I agree with representative DeSimone you
know there's a lot of schools where it's
easily walkable for students me I went
to a high school that was in another
town and I had to drive there but I
would see students walking to there and
many of them were between the ages of 14
to 18 and that was perfectly okay
because their houses were just down the
street you know me on the other hand I
don't think it'd be safe to walk down a
highway or two to get to high school but
125 yes
Route 4 and 125 yeah oh
um but I think that a lot of parents
know what they
their children are capable of doing at
certain ages you know uh they switch
their car seats from facing backwards
different words after a certain age
because of safety reasons but
you know I don't think that
having such a vague law to dictate oh
this is child abuse because they're
riding their bikes to their friends you
know it's
they're going to a friends most of the
parents know that friends they talk to
their parents they get to know their
parents you know they intermingle and I
think that a lot of parents know what's
best for their children uh
especially when it comes to like hey you
can go over to little Susie's house
which is down the street
and if they were doing something really
wrong
a good faith complaint could be filed
see previous bill yeah yeah
anyone else representative Raymond waves
off are you waving off for you no I'd
like to see you waving at me okay yes
representative Wayman Raymond Raymond
sorry I try and like lean forward and
catch your attention because I'm in like
the blind Corner your sincerity is much
appreciated thank you thank you um thank
you for letting me speak I think that it
sounds based on the nods and the smiles
I'm seeing around this table it sounds
like we're pretty much in agreement as
um a committee and I just think that's
fantastic
um New Hampshire has a great system of
um really trusting our families and our
kids to really generally do the right
thing I do think there are situations
where we've got you know two and
three-year-olds who shouldn't be left
home alone and those parents need some
education but that's kind of what dcyf
is for it's why they send social workers
out to help families when they have made
a misstep this this language I don't
think
adds anything
um to state law that isn't there nor
will I think it nor do I think it will
change the practice of many families
um or our dcif workers so I don't see
that it is helpful
um so
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman
um I actually like this amendment for
the reasons what uh representative
Bickford had mentioned before that it
might
provide guidance for parents whether
you know whether they know that they can
allow these activities because I too
like representative DeSimone have looked
up like what can I allow like my child
to do at what age you know how old does
my child have to be to be home alone
type of type of things I've had I've had
I've looked those up as well and so by
giving the parents
um guidance uh I think that's helpful
also I think it's helpful for people in
the community to know that you know this
parent is not being neglectful that you
know you see their kid outside and the
parents inside you know and and the kid
is just playing and riding their bike
around around town like they're not
doing anything wrong
um and so I think that the intent of
this bill would be to to drive down the
number of calls to dcyf that you know so
and so in my town is you know not
watching their child because you know I
always see the child around without the
parent
um and those types of calls happen so I
think that there's actually good intent
behind this language the only thing that
I see a problem with is the remaining in
the vehicle unattended because of the
hot weather
um
I would like to see that little furries
taken out but all the rest of it I don't
representative long
thank you Mr chairman the problem I see
with this being put in in uh statute is
if a mature child is writing to their
friend's house and something happens to
them
do we go after the parent because they
allow them to do that
so when you put something in a statue
saying that that is allowed and
something happens to the child I mean
every child is different
every parent's flexibility with what
they'll allow their child to do is
different and that's the way I think it
should remain the way uh
marginson uh related first of all she
said there is no issue currently with
with this so why so putting this in I
believe would make it an issue
my comment would be that if if we went
with this new language I don't know if
it would cut down the calls to dcyf
because I don't know how many people
read the rsas of New Hampshire
I think
so I mean what difference would it make
anyone else yes representative Nelson I
think that we don't even need to
speculate about the intent of this bill
because the sponsor isn't here
so I don't feel like we even need to be
wasting our time speculating because we
don't know why the sponsor desired to
write this Bill thank you except when
the sponsor is not here we can speculate
all we want and get away with it
maybe that's not good though
excuse me I wouldn't I wouldn't go there
with a sponsor issue because he you know
he may have covid for all we know and
it's not opposition now but
representative Moulton brings up a good
point and and I agree totally with this
and that's why I'm going with it is this
will help limit
reports and then we just heard her bill
about how many reports that they get
and uh people wanting to go maliciously
to prosecute people that may be doing
false reporting
and they do get a lot of reports right
now people have to guess whether it's
okay to do that or not
um representative Simoni
call dcyf represent Bolton called dcyf
to get an opinion
we should have it in Statue and whether
they read it or not it doesn't matter
the word will get out from the statue
it's in writing now it's not somebody's
opinion over at dcyf then somebody else
is going to have a different opinion
maybe this is clear and the word I like
the most here is the word maturity and
we do lose that in child law uh family
law
um the word what maturity maturity when
you go to court the court uses it too
for uh a child to be able to testify
depends on the maturity
um when we talk about
slipped my mind now there's something
else so but maturity is a key word here
and yes as representative long says well
it's somebody else's interpretation of
that interpretation
but we should put it out there that this
is our our our
line that we're using that 11 year old
sometimes very mature that's the thing
that dcyf would make the decisions on
whether they're immature or not and the
parents need to from now on
keep track of that child more closely
so that's why I'm I'm going to go with
it regardless of whether it's sponsors
here or not representative uh
Petrino
thank you Mr chairman
um respectfully I'm really not concerned
with how many calls dcyf gets I think in
every instance we must air
um on the side of the child
um that I think is Paramount and for the
most part I think parents make
Common Sense decisions
and most of us know when there is in
fact neglect or when parents are just
simply letting kids be kids and walk to
school and ride their bicycles I'm
sitting here thinking of just one
instance that I observed of a mom who
basically in my view abandoned her child
let the child sit on a sidewalk while
she decided to go rollerblading then I
came out of a shop
and I saw this child sitting there
crying and I I asked what's what's wrong
my mom is gone and so I called the
police and after about 10 minutes here
came mom on her rollerblade just leaving
that child on the sidewalk clearly
that's abusive and so the bottom line is
this I think we know when children are
neglected and when parents are just
being good parents and whenever there's
any doubt always air with caution on the
side of the child
foreign
representative Raymond thank you for
your Indulgence Mr chairman uh just one
final thought on on this and the word
maturity because I do think that that is
a key here
um
there are situations where it might be
safer for me to expect my 12 year old to
walk to school then for my 15 year old
or 16 year old because I know the 12
year old is motivated and is going to
make it to school whereas my 15 or 16
year old is going to take the
opportunity to skip for the day so you
know it's important for us to allow
parents
to make these kinds of decisions for
themselves without saying well there you
know if the child is old enough by age
and old enough by maturity well you may
not know that your kid's not mature
enough to handle something until you
give them that responsibility and they
fail to follow through that's part of
like the learning and growing of normal
child development
um so I hesitate to put exceptions in
the neglect law
um because each child is so unique in
each family situation is so unique and I
just you know there are some families
where you could leave teenagers home for
a weekend and it would be fine they
might have a friend over they're not
going to have a raging party but there
are other teenagers the same age who you
could not trust to be alone overnight
because they're going to make poor
decisions and I I think that we need to
trust parents to engage in that type of
thinking as opposed to
asking dcif or putting in statute what
are what the standards are I mean we
need to help parents do some of this
parenting work so would you then be for
the bill or not for the Bill I'm not for
the bill because I think I I mean I I as
you know I used to work for tcyf I went
out one summer to a nine-year-old who
was home alone while the parents worked
full-time they were not scared they had
a big dog like they were totally
comfortable they had a plan what to do
if someone came to the door what to do
if there was a fire what like they had
it nailed you know and I've been out to
15 year olds who you know I wouldn't
trust them to watch a goldfish so it
really depends on the individual family
and what's going on with that child's
development and where they are you know
mental health-wise and if they're having
a good day there's just so many factors
and
um I hate to boil it down to like one
long sentence that would say that this
is okay and you know in all
circumstances if you have a kid who's
old enough and mature enough we do have
another bill coming up are we about
kicking this one to death done with you
think maybe 20 minutes ago call the
question the question before us is House
Bill 490 an act relative to modifying
the definition of neglect
the motion is itl moved by
representative Grossmont and seconded by
representative Nelson would the clerk
please call the roll this is an itl so
if you are for the bill
you vote no on Ito if you are against
chairman Pearson
against the bills
that was mostly for me
representative long yes I had to compose
myself
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford oh
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yeah representative ball
representative panic
yes representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
C
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton
yes representative Raymond yes itl
passes 14-2 that can go on consent
unless one of the no voters would like
that's it so okay for consent
okay representative Grossmont Z
Anka and either one of the no votes May
write a contrary opinion as long as you
get it to the clerk
and somebody stepped up to do it has
already done one representative Bali
gonna write a negative a no
he didn't want them so you know it has
I've already done one so I'm referring
to you
okay
open the house the hearing on House Bill
551 an act relative to the Department of
Children youth families tracking and
Publishing statistics
the chair calls representative Corcoran
that you're now recognizes Vice chairman
long
thank you Mr chairman I'll uh
I'd like to introduce House Bill 551 FN
relative to department of children youth
and families tracking and Publishing
statistics
thank you sir the chair recognizes our
friend Beth margison from dcyf to speak
thank you very much Mr chair Vice chair
and members of the committee I
appreciate the opportunity to speak on
this bill
um to a certain extent we'd love a
website but some of the information that
is being asked to be tracked here we're
not able to track
um and uh so we would say that we're
probably against the bill
um and um for instance the you know
children who this is nine three on page
two letter L number and percent of such
children knew it all their required
immunizations by the first day of the
school year that is obviously not
information that we could actually track
and and publish for the public so
um but if you want to give us a website
for other things we'd be happy for that
but and we do actually publish
statistics I'm so sorry it's so hard to
see over the side we do uh publish
statistics related to our abuse and
neglect cases on the Department of
Health and Human Services website
currently and we of course would always
Endeavor to make that more user friendly
so
so you do have a lot of data and you
publish it we do we do and it is
I have a question under Roman numeral
three
does and I believe it should be doesn't
maintain such a website with at least 99
percent uptime
the director of dcyf shall be relieved
of his or her position and no division
of Department of New Hampshire
government shall employ retain a
contractor in any capacity of the
relieved director
um I think that might put a little bit
of a chill on hiring at your place it
representative Bickford uh thank you Mr
chairman well that was my question also
and I didn't understand what uptime
means
do you know what it means here as we
understand it that it's up that it's
actually up and available for use as
opposed to down yeah oh well so I think
but I'm not an I.T persons I think if
we're to reverse of what the person
intended I I think so I think that they
probably meant does not maintain such a
website yeah I hate to see you get fired
for keeping the thing running yes
okay
you know for the record I really do like
statistics I chair the New Hampshire
commission for the deaf and hard of
hearing and one of the things that
bothers us is there is a pathological
fear in this state of actually recording
any information and it makes it very
difficult for the deaf Community for us
to know who what we need where so I do
like stats but what I read in this bill
is like stats on speed
yes statistics do you agree yes
statistics are important data is
important especially when you're talking
about the work that we do it's it's very
very important we do publish stats and
data we're always looking to improve
things we did do a fiscal analysis on
this this bill and
um we found that actually getting a
vendor to do this kind of website
assuming everything's included would be
about a million dollars and uh it would
probably cost a vendor three full-time
employment three full-time employees
about a year keeping it up about 500 000
so but yes I so that is you know the
fiscal analysis that we did on it but
yes we we agree we statistics and data
are very important stipulating the
purpose of good data is so that one can
make good decisions do you believe the
department presently collects data in a
sufficient way as to forward your
program in a good way we do but we're
always looking for ways to improve it's
a constant Improvement so we get a lot
of our data and anecdotal data so my
follow-up is so there might be a line
item or two in this long list that maybe
makes a suggestions man maybe we can do
that yes we
we would love to have more money to do
all right thank you so much and with
that I conclude the hearing on House
Bill 551 and with that I open the exact
session on the same and the chair is
oh wow
would you believe that was a tie
representative Panic what is your
emotion I motion to itl
thank you and who would like to Second
it representative levack I saw her hand
and will remember for the next time the
v e
a bunch of letters we don't pronounce
okay
listen you listen this is your day
you've been off testifying elsewhere and
and and woohoo and and you won the tie
on this one anyway and so um before you
leave tonight that's all we're
reasonable here
anybody else want to say anything about
the bill that you were all thinking no
where's your family from originally or
the Panic family is
control
you could write it in Polish if you want
yeah
okay
all right I'm killing time to help
people who might uh be too shy now to
put their hand up no that didn't work
okay the motion before us is House Bill
551 i t l as moved by representative
panic and seconded by representative
Levesque
would the chair please with no that is
me I got to stop saying that would the
assistant clerk please call the roll
yes
Vice chairman long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative panic
representative Seidel yes representative
Grossman yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez
yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
16 uh yes zero knows pass it any
objection to consent seeing none
it's on consent this ends the exact
session on House Bill 551 we will not
meet as a committee next week because it
is super Tuesday
the governor's state of the state's
address
voting sessions in the house before and
after we will meet two weeks from today
and we'll be taking up a bunch of things
when I figure out exactly what I will
shoot you an email so you'll have good
advanced notice representative long
so at the chair and vice chairs meeting
there are some committees that we're
going to meet during a break are we one
of those committees I hope not okay so
we're not one of those on vacation
correct no I've been no okay telling the
chair for six years now we need to take
a break okay great and I'm not no way
are you go go somewhere for school
vacation okay
happened I am not going to another I'm
not going back to health and human
services
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I'll give you a question mark sure yeah
okay
questions
s
things
um
oh and if you just can't decide the
street
s